programming throwdown episode 163 recursion take it away patrick i was trying to come up with a good intro topic for the show and and I decided to harass Jason. So I apologize. No, no, I'm just teasing. I want to talk about electric cars. So electric cars have always been about to be a thing. I actually am not strongly opinionated about whether they will be this sort of exponential adoption thing that I feel like a lot of tech people feel this is like what will happen like it'll just become more and more inconvenient to go to the gas station there
won't be gas stations and then overnight you'll blink and everyone will have electric cars i don't know not going to get into that per se but i have noticed a lot more people uh driving electric cars so jason and i were talking about it briefly but basically so i drive a plug-in hybrid which i actually really really like i drive a honda version called a clarity i don't even think they make it anymore um but what's the plug-in part mean yeah okay plug-in hybrid so that's great so a prius most people know about the prius is just like a hybrid it means that you have a you know electric motor to drive your wheels but you have a gas engine to run effectively as a generator to make the electricity and in something like a prius it just sort of does this all the time but it has batteries
won't be gas stations and then overnight you'll blink and everyone will have electric cars i don't know not going to get into that per se but i have noticed a lot more people uh driving electric cars so jason and i were talking about it briefly but basically so i drive a plug-in hybrid which i actually really really like i drive a honda version called a clarity i don't even think they make it anymore um but what's the plug-in part mean yeah okay plug-in hybrid so that's great so a prius most people know about the prius is just like a hybrid it means that you have a you know electric motor to drive your wheels but you have a gas engine to run effectively as a generator to make the electricity and in something like a prius it just sort of does this all the time but i has batteries
it can short-term kind of store the energy and deliver and i might be mistaken i may have changed over the years about priuses but as a an abstraction this will work so basically it runs the gas engine and it can store um sort of power but every time you turn your car off and turn it back back on you're sort of more or less starting from scratch like it doesn't intend to build up a lot of uh energy so it doesn't have big batteries because batteries are pretty expensive they're also pretty heavy um and so your engine will run from from time to time so there's not really an expected mode of operation where you would go on an entire trip and not use your engine um and so it's sort of more along the spectrum of like even
modern cars when you stop at a stoplight will just turn off the the engine and has like a little bit of i actually don't know how they did it but like you know a little bit of it can kind of start quickly and get you going without you kind of noticing so it's just a more extreme version of that although it predated it um and then it kind of reminds me of the formula one cars like the formula one cars have a battery and uh whenever you hit the brakes it charges the battery and so that builds up and builds up and then when they're ready to pass somebody they turn on the battery and the motor and then that makes them super fast yeah so regenerative braking is this like using the motor that's sort of attached to the the spinning part
of the the wheels to charge up to to basically act as a generator which of course pulling the energy there's you know conservation of energy kind of thing like you know charging the battery makes it harder to turn the motor, which makes you slow down. And so you're recapturing some of that energy, which is a really good idea, which is why it's pretty efficient. So the plug in idea is, like most of the original Priuses, you couldn't like plug them into the wall wouldn't do anything, there wasn't like a large battery to charge up plug in hybrid sort of is that it's just sort of like an electric car where you can plug it in, and you plug it in to charge it up and there's a battery that lasts some amount of miles in my car it's something
i i forget the range i think it's like 30 or 40 miles so most of the commute you know like oh i just go you know up to the grocery store i go to you know the office or whatever just like briefly these things are only you know for me like eight miles. So I can go there and back and I don't have to use the gas engine at all. So I have a very small gas tank. It's only like seven gallons, I think is what it is like very, very tiny. Oh, wow. And hardly ever use it. Like I go months and months and never hard. And when I get home at night, I plug the car in the plug in hybrid. But if I'm going to go on a trip, not to worry about finding a charger. So it's on the spectrum of electric cars versus if you go to like a Rivian or a Tesla or something like that. There is no gas engine.
So I used to have a Nissan Leaf. It was the same thing. No gas engine. Had about 100 miles range. So the range of the battery was further. But if I wanted to go on a road trip, I would have had to, you know, stage charging, you know, stops along the way. And so it's on this sort of spectrum, but my observation is just, you know, I'm actually really excited because I think the diversity in the market, I think, you know,
being able to find abundance of choices, not that there's anything particularly wrong with Tesla, but just having more competitors in the market in general i think is is really awesome and it's exciting to see these electric cars start to come out and start to to kind of like make it easier for people who have them to more likely to find a charger somewhere because people are more incentivized to build chargers still sometimes i'll show up somewhere and like charge and people kind of look at you like oh that thing gets used i thought that was just like a reserve spot that you know has the charger added at the mall like some of the economies around that are a little weird still but uh just
you know it's kind of exciting there's lots of debate about where the energy comes from in the ecological the uh environmental impacts there we go of uh you know making the electric cars versus making gas car trying to get into all that but just as a like convenience and i don't have to go to gas stations there's like less sophisticated moving parts in a fully electric car uh versus you know the kind of hybrid is it's got more because that's you know kind of a lot of the traditional stuff and the electric car stuff um but you know it's kind of nice that in general not having to go to the gas station you just kind of forget how inconvenient it is especially where we happen to live now for whatever reason they just haven't like looked at the census data who knows to like build a gas
station so there's like no gas station on any of our like regular occurring routes so we have to like go visit the gas station to get gas which is horrible going to the gas station so when you say you plug it in it's a plug-in hybrid did you have to get the 220 volt adapter for your house yeah so this is a good question so we don't so we just charge it off of regular thing like i i know we could do it we could pay we price it out we just chose to do regular because our battery is small enough that we can charge it up overnight basically if you have a you know 300 mile range like fully electric vehicle it would take you sort of i don't know i'd have to look probably like 30 hours or something 20 something hours to charge so if you drained it
station so there's like no gas station on any of our like regular recurring routes so we have to like go visit the gas station to get gas which is horrible going to the gas station so when you say you plug it in it's a plug-in hybrid did you have to get the 220 volt adapter for your house yeah so this is a good question so we don't so we just charge it off of regular thing like i i know we could do it we could pay we price it out we just chose to do regular because our battery is small enough that we can charge it up overnight basically if you have a you know 300 mile range like fully electric vehicle it would take you sort of i don't know i'd have to look probably like 30 hours or something 20 something hours to charge so if you drained it
all the way down and there's no backup right so um that would that would definitely be a call for a quick charge versus for me it's only if i like went somewhere far in the morning and came home having 220 would only be useful to like get it back up so i could go again in the afternoon versus now if i do that i just have to use gas yeah i mean i think this is super exciting um if you go on a long trip with a seven gallon tank are you refilling very very often or how does work? So the car basically reverts to being a normal hybrid. So it still gets, I don't know, whatever. The mile per gallon stuff is a little weird. Anyway, it goes to whatever the normal mile per gallon you would get on a hybrid is.
So it's still very efficient. It'll still shut off the engine. It'll still, you know, do regenerative braking like you were saying. So I think I get something like 40, 50, 60 miles per gallon. Oh, that's great. So it's still very efficient. So that's a nice fallback not pitching poigan hybrids they all have their thoughts just kind of like you heard it here first no no and i think like i said i think honda stopped making my car so they don't even make it anymore oh no and where i live they never sold the car in this state so um actually
it's like very unique i've only ever seen one other of this car in the entire you know time i've been living here because we moved from california so in california they sold a lot of them here they don't so actually i'm like the only one with that car yeah i think in california um you can't have a combustion engine car after some time like yeah pretty soon they're going to change it yeah yeah that uh it's really interesting yeah i have a friend another friend who has a fully electric car i can't remember what it is not a tesla but it's something else but it is fully electric and um um you know he was he i think it is a honda uh does honda make a fully electric as well or no uh is that the ionique or something maybe yes it could be but oh no that's he would he was saying
that uh you know the nice thing is you know it's just as you said you never have to think about the gas station and uh you know plugging it in when you get home is is so much more convenient than the gas station plus you know the gas station causes some like latent anxiety it's like you watch it's like a half full a fourth full an eighth full and then you go in but that whole time you know you have to kind of keep it in your mind um so yeah i think uh i have a feeling like the next car we buy once one of our cars finally kicks the bucket is gonna have some type of battery in it well your car has a battery in it now to be fair okay yes i know what you're saying some type of battery powered engine propulsion electric propulsion of some sort yeah i think uh
um i think the hybrid is you know has a lot of nice advantages so i have a feeling the hybrid is probably what about the gasoline like if the gasoline sits in the car because you're not using the engine is that bad do you have to every now and then just go on the highway or something? Yeah. I mean, if you probably like over the course of very, very long time, but I do notice I,
I'm not a car nerd as anyone who is probably already is, is owning and passporting, but the, the, the gas tank is like, I think it's pressurized or something to help avoid that. So like when you push the gas tank release button, it actually takes like a good five seconds before it like makes kind of a special noise and then opens up so i think they do something to keep it like a more sealed thing to
prevent which makes sense then yeah you know a lot of the issues you might otherwise have um you know so don't pop up but i've never had an issue with it and we do routinely run it you know every so often um so we do go fill it up every couple of months it's not like we go two years and never you know never use it so very cool all right interesting we'll have to see well actually we'll end it with a prediction like uh at the end of this year how many what percent of cars will be either hybrid or electric actually i don't know the percent right now here let me look at this this sounds this sounds sketchy no i'm just gonna say i think it's like you i think the prediction is like what will and there's no way to like get a metric for it it's just like what percentage of people
will seriously consider uh like let's say sort of on the spectrum a plug-in hybrid to electric like something that can drive you know some tens of miles without using gas uh is that going to be you know a third of people a half of people i think some people like you're going to buy a pickup truck because you work construction you're not probably going to consider very strongly a fully electric car maybe that'd be great but so i like in the next five years what percentage of car purchase car purchasers will consider like a fully electric vehicle wow this is nuts i don't know if this includes hybrids but it says this is april 3rd of this year electric vehicles account for less than one percent of vehicles sold in the u.s
i feel like that maybe you know it's just perception bias but man it feels like that that number is a little low um all right anyways on so yeah i guess now that i've seen such a shockingly low number it's hard for me to have a prediction so we'll just table that you want to just take one percent yeah yeah my prediction is two percent oh that's pretty good that's doubling more than doubling that's actually how we do math on programming throwdown all right time for news you have the first news go for it yeah i do so i actually have a great article for this which is like some running thing that i was observing i think it's kind of the same
person or people uh we've talked about code golf in the past um and this interesting spiral this person was posting a sort of ever declining number of bites that they've managed to make the game of snake you know where you like turn left right up down like eat the little pixel i guess it's supposed to be a fruit a snake don't eat fruit but you know like the snake going around and eating and growing slightly longer until you you know crash into yourself um so someone has been trying to get that uh assembly version of that lower and lower and lower in number of bytes they were at the one i have here linked in the show notes they made it to 101 bytes pushing for that you know getting below triple digit number of bytes to encode the snake game but they've been putting it in a qr code and boy did this get
people very divisive about this so uh really yeah so i i am aware of a lot of security kind of concerns but i'm not overly uh i want to say paranoid that adds a negative stigma to it but i am not overly uh cautious about maybe stuff i do i probably choose convenience more than i ought to i'll say yeah same here um but people were saying oh my gosh why would you try to tell people to like take a picture of a untrusted unauthenticated like qr code especially one that you intend to run like who knows what exploit in it and then just like people coming out now to be clear i don't know what percentage of computer professionals would be represented by the noisy people in the threads but basically like how it is a terrible idea to ever take a
picture of a qr code because it could just be like an exploit waiting to happen right like could take you to a payload it could take you to whatever like you're asking you're basically clicking a link and everybody would say oh don't click a link emailed to you but most people would say oh you know qr code what's the worst that can happen now i don't know how many vectors or how many proven sort of like problems have come through people randomly snapping qr codes like out in the wild but it is a concern but i thought this is sort of one of those like unintended rat holes or whatever or like you think you're going to read about someone like you know clever ways or people collaborating on other you know optimizations they could do to get their
size lower and lower or just being happy or oh how cool this is or references to demo scene you know 4k demos or whatever and those those things were there. But then this whole other like brigade of like, QR codes are the worst. It was Yeah, I've seen I've seen some video where somebody basically showed how to exploit this where they were at a restaurant and they stuck a sticker on top of the QR code for the menu, then like sent them to their own site but uh but yeah i mean i i mean what you're hint what you're pointing at is interesting it's like the serendipity of the internet where um you know i had i mean you don't have any social media accounts patrick so i'll have to lecture you i have to lecture me about it please i i i had a post on linkedin basically this is years ago but i was just really excited that I got promoted.
And I was based on my post. The gist of my post was, you know, I never thought that I would really make it this far. I was really happy and, you know, real thankful. And I think like, you know, like some professors from like a long time ago and stuff, right? And it was, it felt really good to make that post. And that post went viral and got tens of thousands of likes on linkedin and then uh basically there was a whole ton of comments about how my university is like a crap university and and uh i you know it was the thing where like uh i wasn't mentally equipped to like to like uh you know moderate something like that so i basically just left it and uh it turns out linkedin is really good at moderation because i went back
months later and all those comments were gone i don't know how that happened it wasn't me i didn't delete interesting yeah so so there's something some kind of uh moderation going on there but um but same kind of thing where it's like yeah i made this post just to talk about you know just celebrate something and it turned into like this whole like back and forth about like where i went to college and uh you know that's just the internet i mean it's it makes it like kind of scary to say anything oh dear yeah i don't know yeah i'm probably doing the right thing youtube videos and i see the comments and i'm just like oh i don't know i could never be a youtube creator i would just
have all my comments turned off uh just yeah about the littlest things there's no like sense of collaboration or like yuki said you know people just move on like why do you need to take pot shots at someone's university so yeah i mean i i think uh um we had comments initially on the blog and uh there's a lot of spam and and there was like some divisiveness and so we just decided to turn it off and yeah comments i mean that's a whole separate rat hole but like whether you should have comments or not i mean someone should write like a dissertation on that yeah i there's some i'm not much into the like uh publicize your podcast i was listening to a podcast the other day and the podcasters
on the podcast were talking about another podcast where they were saying the person's thesis is sort of like you want to be really controversial because like the stuff like you're saying you should have actually leaned into it and like doubled down on it and like gotten people riled up because then people will make other posts that link to your post which will make your post even even more important and like basically you should be like controversially optimizing so even if you don't really believe it you should like make a follow-up post saying where i won't say because you didn't say it the name of your university is like the best university because now you know like the yeah right you
have been given a pearl you have been given a surprise treasure which you now know that your university is apparently divisive therefore you should double down on it and start more controversy and this will like propel you to fame and theoretically fortune or success or whatever these people are optimizing for yeah they call this the attention economy right i mean i was listening to something about um i listened to this board game creators podcast because i think people who make board games for a living are just fascinating um you know and uh they were talking about how to do well on kickstarter and basically a big part of it is already having an audience so so i mean you know one sort of really odd way to get there is to start a bunch of controversy, uh, build up a lot of followers
and then bring them all over to Kickstarter to buy your stuff. Oh, we should. Okay. I don't want to get under the Kickstarter. Yeah. That could take forever. All right. Yeah. All right. My, my, my news is superconductor rumors abound. So room temperature, superconductors. So, um, I'm sure you've heard about this,
Patrick. Uh, there's this thing, I think it's LK 99 or 77 or something. Okay. 99. It's, it's,
uh, some kind of, and you, when I read the instructions of how to make it, it didn't look that weird. I was kind of expecting the instructions to be like, you know, like build a nuclear bunker, you know, hit chemicals with nuclear bombs or like something crazy like you'd see from CERN or something. But no, it's actually like here, take these materials, do this stuff. And it seemed like, yeah, like relatively straightforward um and so uh they're claiming that you'd have a room
uh, some kind of, and you, when I read the instructions of how to make it, it didn't look that weird. I was kind of expecting the instructions to be like, youG know, like build a nuclear bunker, you know, hit chemicals with nuclear bombs or like something crazy like you'd see from CERN or something. But no, it's actually like here, take these materials, do this stuff. And it seemed like, yeah, like relatively straightforward
temperature superconductor which you know i think if true like opens up a ton of different possibilities i mean just one and i'm sure patrick you have even better ones but just off top my head you know think about how much power is wasted in getting electricity from the power plant to your house right i don't know the number but it's got to be very high amount of power is wasted and you know if you had room temperature superconductors you could theoretically bring that to zero or at least get it a lot closer to zero um and that's just one of you know people are saying you could have gpus that don't get hot and stuff that i'm not totally sure how that would work. But there's definitely huge application for it.
and so uh they're claiming that you'd have a room temperature superconductor which you know i think if true like opens up a ton of different possibilities i mean just one and i'm sure patrick you have even better ones but just off top my head you know think about how much power is wasted in getting electricity from the power plant to your house right i don't know the number but it's got to be very high amount of power is wasted and you know if you had room temperature superconductors you could theoretically bring that to zero or at least get it a lot closer to zero um and that's just one of you know people are saying you could have gpus that don't get hot and stuff that i'm not totally sure how that would work. But there's definitely huge application for it.
And now everyone's rushing to see. Oh, and then there was all this controversy around, I guess, the way they announced it. They didn't go through the typical channels. And so, you know, people are not sure whether it's real or not and uh uh it's just kind of a crazy situation right now i oh man uh like this is similar to what we were just talking about opening sort of pandora's box uh which of the random threads should we pretend to be experts on so the amount of like people coming out of the woodwork claiming to know things about super conductors or like what their implications are or like whatever on on sort of i'll guess we call it
x now about like right on x on x uh twitter uh the the social media network everyone's on x we have a serious uh epidemic oh no uh but yeah so so i i mean like a couple of things just to like like my my sort of like thoughts to your thoughts we have heard a lot of the same stuff um a lot of weirdness around like how this was announced a lot of debate that i've seen which is kind of interesting around like should we go through the normal peer review process or is this actually like better this distributed stuff and people sort of countering? Well, this is a big waste, because if this truly is a fake, or like a dead end, then like all of this, like random people stopping what they're doing startups putting money
x now about like right on x on x  twitter  the social media network everyone's on x we have a serious  epidemic oh no  uh but yeah so so i  mean like a couple of things just to like like my my sort of like thoughts to your thoughts we have heard a lot of the same stuff  a lot of weirdness around like how this was announced a lot of debate that i've seen which is kind of interesting around like should we go through the normal peer review process or is this actually like better this distributed stuff and people sort of countering? Well, this is a big waste, because if this truly is a fake, or like a dead end, then like all of this, like random people stopping what they're doing startups putting money
into this, and like this race to all become the first to market or whatever, is like a waste of resources on a global level, it's much better to have like one or two very focused people sort of proving it out. Other folks saying, well, well no that's the way you just end up with patents and then it like is protected very interesting discourse i'm not an academic person so i have no i have no uh pony in that race so moving on to the next one but like you know like your your sort of claims like oh imagine like wasted power lines well so just the whole thing of like economics like even if you took it to zero the thing still has to be as cheap as copper wire and even then it has to be a good point so even like even if it was a room temperature or even high you know above far above room
into this, and like this race to all become the first to market or whatever, is like a waste of resources on a global level, it's much better to have like one or two very focused people sort of proving it out. Other folks saying, well, well no that's the way you just end up with patents and then it like is protected very interesting discourse i'm not an academic person so i have no i have no  pony in that race so moving on to the next one but like you know like your your  sort of claims like oh imagine like wasted power lines well so just the whole thing of like economics like even if you took it to zero the thing still has to be as cheap as copper wire and even then it has to be a good point so even like even if it was a room temperature or even high  you know above far above room
temperature it might not be very ductile it may not be able to be put into wires right easily or economically and then things like you were saying people were talking about oh batteries that never run out and your phone and like gpus that don't get hot and then this descends into which which i was telling people land hours principle and reversible computing which is this idea like if you destroy we we have referenced this before but if you like make a computation like an and gate is one and zero zero and zero zero and one all have the same output of zero so information is lost you had two bits of information now you have one and there is a theorem sort of saying that losing that bit of information has a minimal threshold of like wasted energy because of the lost bit of information which says even if you had superconductors even if you had new
silicon whatever gpus would still get hot maybe not as hot maybe you don't need a fan but they're not going to be it's not like a you know zero end game there is still waste energy your iphone your android phone in your pocket still will consume energy and so there's like a lot of this like you're sort of saying oh we'll just you know put put electrons into the superconductor in a big loop and then we'll have you know basically better batteries so folks are pointing out actually superconductors have like this quenching property which is if you if the magnetic flux again not this is not my background basically exceeds some amount basically put too much electron circling around they build a magnetic field the magnetic field actually sort of quenches the
superconducting ability the thing that makes the superconducting above a certain magnetic threshold like causes it to fail and this is a big concern actually in mri machines the large hadron collider had a quench event that apparently like the magnetic flux and one of the big magnet coils that are superconducting that they have that they chill to very low temperatures today had like a over too high of magnetism and it basically destroyed the superconductor and caused like a large portion of the hadron collider to need to be repaired so there's like all these like second order phenomena so people just hear something akin to like perpetual motion or free energy and get like
whoa it's like well hang on it is a huge market it is it is going to open up applications we don't know of today but it's not like every bit of history is like rewritten because of you know the magic material but still very interesting i watch it every day i log on to see like has someone been able to there's a lot of weirdness and how it gets made and no one really knows how to do it and uh so is it true is it like meaningful and you know can we actually figure out a way to produce it may be a decade before like even the first practical applications come out even if it turns out to be the sort of like holy grail everyone was seeking yeah here's what i think we need to do patrick i think you and i need to start a petition
whoa it's like well hang on it is a huge market it is it is going to open up applications we don't know of today but it's not like every bit of history is like rewritten because of you know the magic material but still very interesting i watch it every day i log on to see like has someone been able to there's a lot of weirdness and how it gets made and no one really knows how to do it and  so is it true is it like meaningful and you know can we actually figure out a way to produce it may be a decade before like even the first practical applications come out even if it turns out to be the sort of like holy grail everyone was seeking yeah here's what i think we need to do patrick i think you and i need to start a petition
saying that for the next six months we need to have a moratorium on uh on superconductors and only we can work on it for the next six months then we need to petition that one i didn't know where you were going we need we do superconductor safety is like a primary government license that's right yeah and everyone except us should be banned from uh doing work on superconductors are you gonna at least tell people what the joke is there yes that's that's a reference to the uh six month moratorium on ai that was proposed. I think even Elon Musk signed it. A whole bunch of people who would definitely not stop for six months signed it. But they want you to stop for the next six months.
saying that for the next six months we need to have a moratorium on  on superconductors and only we can work on it for the next six months then we need to petition that one i didn't know where you were going we need we do superconductor safety is like a primary government license that's right yeah and everyone except us should be banned from  doing work on superconductors are you gonna at least tell people what the joke is there yes that's that's a reference to the  six month moratorium on ai that was proposed. I think even Elon Musk signed it. A whole bunch of people who would definitely not stop for six months signed it. But they want you to stop for the next six months.
All right, on that note, Patrick, you want to talk about OpenWorm. What is OpenWorm? Okay, now on to something completely different, but I also don't know about. But I found this is fascinating. So I've seen this for a few years. It came up again recently. They made some progress. So open worm is a project to attempt to create,
I think it's, I don't even know what the C stands for, C. elegans, some kind of like little flatworm that is composed of a few thousand cells. And they want to make a simulation of the worm now many people have made like simulators of worms before but they normally kind of go top down so they sort of start with the behaviors and then they make like a simulator or model that like does those behaviors right i mean we all play video games is basically how video games work like when you have a video game you know enemy that you're chasing around a level
they are not simulating the cells of the organism. They're like taking the behavior and then like applying behavior to a sprite, right? It's kind of more top down, but here they're actually trying to go bottom up. So because this elegance, I don't even know if I'm saying that right.
Worm is so, so simple. They have done what they call like the connectome. So the neurons that, uh, you know, are the, the worms intelligence, the neurons that uh you know are the the worms intelligence they know how each of them are connected to each other and so here they're trying to model the actual like chemicals flowing between the neurons the electrical impulses back
Worm is so, so simple. They have done what they call like the connectome. So the neurons that,  you know, are the, the worms intelligence, the neurons that  u know are the  the worms intelligence they know how each of them are connected to each other and so here they're trying to model the actual like chemicals flowing between the neurons the electrical impulses back
and then saying things like i move this this cell is a muscle cell so if it gets this kind of level of chemical it's going to shrink in size or grow in size and that's going to move against the environment and then that's going to cause pressure on this sensory nerve which is going to uptick its chemical output and sort of doing this entirely bottoms up sort of not at the like atomic level like there is still you know some amount right picking something in the middle but there's much more sort of cellular level model each cell and then sort of see if you have the emergent property again of like basically a silicon simulation of the worm that could one day even you know find mates and have eggs and those eggs could grow up in this environment and even
然后说，比如“我移动这个，这个细胞是一个肌肉细胞，所以如果它受到这种水平的化学物质影响，它就会收缩或膨胀，这会促使其抵抗周围环境，从而对这个感觉神经施加压力，这会提高其化学物质的输出。”他们完全从这种自下而上的角度去做，并不是在原子水平上——当然仍然有一定数量的原子，比如在中间选定某种东西——但它是一个更偏向细胞水平的模型，对每个细胞进行建模，然后看看你是否能再次获得像蠕虫的硅模拟这样的涌现属性，它甚至有一天可以寻找配偶、产卵，并且这些卵可以在这个环境中长大，甚至
amazing refine their genes and pass on stuff and you could just but right now computationally this is like even for as far as we have for a simple simple worm like that's actually i don't say cutting edge to kind of do this bottoms up for a few thousand cells and you can sort of go watch the videos not in real time but of the the sort of worm wiggling around its environment and trying to make its way uh and it's just like a really fascinating like something at first you'd be like this is really silly and then you're like whoa i don't even like it would take me probably a month of or more reading to actually even appreciate what they're actually doing here yeah this is wild i'm trying to figure out who actually uh is behind this oh like uh like what group
惊人地完善它们的基因并遗传下去，你完全可以……但就目前而言，在计算层面上，即使对于我们所了解的这样一条简单得不能再简单的蠕虫来说，这实际上——我并不是说这是前沿技术——要为几千个细胞以这种自下而上的方式进行建模，你可以去看看相关的视频，虽然不是实时的，但能看到那种蠕虫在环境中扭动并试图前行的样子，这真的非常吸引人。一开始你可能会觉得这太愚蠢了，然后你会觉得：“哇，我甚至可能需要花一个月或更多的时间去阅读，才能真正领略他们在这里到底做了什么。”是的，这太疯狂了，我正试图弄清楚到底是谁在背后主导这个项目。哦，就像……
yeah well it's actually like uh they have a board of directors um wow it's like a ton of folks it must be uh some kind of um it's a not-for-profit corporation this is wild yeah folks should definitely check out this video at first i thought when i saw open worm i thought it was going to be like a worm virus you know like computer virus i thought the same thing i was like someone put source code up for like uh you know computer virus yeah exactly this is phenomenal though it really looks like a worm the way it moves because they're modeling it as such a law so it did how do they reverse engineer the brain i guess i mean that so i think this is like it's a well-studied organism so for like one of the muscle cells people have isolated it and like observed what
是的，其实他们有一个董事会，哇，有超级多的人，这一定是一个某种……这是一个非营利性公司，这太疯狂了。是的，大家绝对应该去看看这段视频。一开始我看到“开源蠕虫”（OpenWorm）时，我还以为它会像某种蠕虫病毒一样，你知道的，就像电脑病毒那样。我也有同感，我当时想，是不是有人把某种电脑病毒的源代码放上去了？是的，完全没错。不过这太牛了，它动起来真的看起来像一条蠕虫，因为他们就是按这种规律对它进行建模的。那么，他们究竟是怎么逆向工程出这个大脑的呢？我是说，所以我觉得这是一个研究得很透彻的生物，比如对于其中一个肌肉细胞，人们已经分离出它并观察了什么样的
stimulus makes it do what output right and so they have models for most of the cells and like i mentioned people talk about like the the genome or like brain scan, but this connectome, which is like neurons are very, these isodendrites and the whole thing, right? These neurons are very long and spindly. This is not how neural networks work in the sort of like large language
刺激会让它产生什么样的输出，对吧？所以他们拥有针对大多数细胞的模型，就像我提到的人们谈论基因组或脑扫描一样，但这个连接组——就像神经元非常……这些树突和整个结构，对吧？这些神经元非常长而且细长。这并不是神经网络在大语言模型中
models, but in, in sort of biology, there's like these very long tendrils and those tendrils overlap and touch each other. So if you sort of freeze very cold, like the sample, and then you slice it very thinly, and then you apply like computer vision to it, you can figure out this cell touches that cell there. So they can
那种工作方式，但在生物学中，有这些非常长的卷须，这些卷须相互重叠并接触。所以如果你把样本冷冻得非常冰冷，然后把它切成极薄的片，再对其应用计算机视觉，你就能弄清楚这个细胞在哪个地方接触了那个细胞。因此他们可以
pass chemicals between an emitter and a receptor. And so you can figure out the sort of network of all the cells together. And then they're basically attempting to simulate that and this is a relatively simple organism and so it's uh it's sort of attainable wow that is wild very cool folks should definitely uh go to the show notes check out the video this is pretty awesome um all right my news this is a relatively short one but a sad one the creator of vim passed away um so he was in his 60s so he wasn't that old 62 um bram i'm probably gonna get this wrong mulinar um and uh i don't i'm assuming he had some kind of health issue um i don't know if it really said oh yeah here we go medical condition that rapidly progressed it didn't say exactly what it was but um you can actually see on github you know he has all this
在发射体和受体之间传递化学物质。这样你就能搞清楚所有细胞组合在一起的网络。然后他们基本上正试图模拟这一点，这是一个相对简单的生物，所以这某种程度上是可实现的。哇，太疯狂了，非常酷。大家绝对应该去查看节目笔记中的视频，这相当棒。好吧，我的新闻，这是一个相对简短的话题，但也是一个令人悲伤的话题：Vim的创造者去世了。他当时60多岁，所以他其实不算太老，62岁。布拉姆——我大概会把他的姓读错——莫利纳尔（Bram Moolenaar），而且……我假设他是有某种健康问题，我不知道这上面有没有明说……哦，对了，这里有：迅速恶化的医疗状况。它没有明确说明具体是什么病，但你实际上可以在GitHub上看到，你知道的，他有所有这些
activity um and then you know right around i think september of october or september or october the activity just stopped uh that that point he must have got some kind of diagnosis or something um so you know yeah i mean i actually uh i wouldn't say i've never used vim um you know it's been on the computer sometime and i've used it because i didn't have emacs i've been more of an emacs person but uh i know vim's been just incredibly influential on everything did you ever were you a vim user patrick i mean only by like i don't want to say necessity i've never hardcore developed and i have edited files in vim and i know how to sort of get around but i've never customized it or attempted to use it as my ide
活动，然后你知道的，大约在9月或10月左右——9月或10月，这些活动就停止了。那个时候他一定得到了某种诊断结果之类的。所以，你知道的，我其实……我不会说我从来没用过Vim，你知道的，电脑上偶尔会有，而且因为我没有Emacs，我也用过它。我一直更偏向于Emacs用户，但我知道Vim对所有事物都有着难以置信的影响力。你曾经是Vim用户吗，帕特里克？我是说，只是出于某种……我不想说是出于必需。我从来没有进行过硬核开发，我确实在Vim中编辑过文件，我也知道怎么大概摸索，但我从未定制过它，也从未尝试将它用作我的IDE。
yeah same here but uh um oh it looks like he's from holland um originally but uh yeah so uh you know uh best wishes to his family and uh you know someone who really created something really special for the community and time for book of the show patrick what's your book of the show my book of the show is the little book of common sense investing uh definitely a good book uh pretty like i would say easy reading but more importantly sort of like what it represents i guess anyways this is a book by a man named jack bogle who passed away a few years ago but jack bogle uh probably most famous for uh starting the vanguard group and so vanguard group which a little united
是的，我也是。但……哦，看起来他原本是荷兰人。但无论如何，向他的家人致以最美好的祝愿，他确实为社区创造了一些非常特别的东西。节目之书的时间到了，帕特里克，你的节目之书是什么？我的节目之书是《共同基金常识小书》（The Little Book of Common Sense Investing）。绝对是一本好书，我觉得读起来相当轻松，但更重要的是，它某种程度上代表了某种理念，我想。不管怎样，这本书的作者是一位名叫杰克·伯格（Jack Bogle）的人，他在几年前去世了。但杰克·伯格可能最著名的事迹就是创立了先锋集团（Vanguard Group）。所以先锋集团，虽然稍微带有美国
states focus for a minute but also i mean has applications to i think a lot of financial markets but basically um his philosophy was rather than doing sort of trading or picking individual stocks he sort of espoused the idea of index funds and of diversification and buy and hold. So rather than sort of, there are lots of other philosophies we can talk about in a minute. Anyways, he sort of had this like, just keep it simple, you know, have, you know, what you think your, you know, allocation should be and sort of just like invest in it. And this will save you fees, it will prevent you from getting into market timing, which he thought wasn't, you know, a thing worth doing. So like a lot of core principles, I feel like now they've gained a lot more traction than
本土视角一会儿，但我也认为它对许多金融市场都有应用价值。基本上，他的哲学是，与其进行某种交易或挑选个股，他更倾向于倡导指数基金、分散投资以及买入并持有的理念。因此，与其进行……我们可以过一会儿讨论许多其他哲学。无论如何，他基本上持有这样一种观点：保持简单，你知道的，确立你认为你的资产配置应该是什么样的，然后就照着投资。这会为你节省费用，还能防止你陷入市场择时的陷阱，而他认为择时是不值得做的事情。所以就像许多核心原则一样，我觉得现在它们比
even sort of 15, 20 years ago. This was a little bit more outlandish. People didn't have 401ks that auto invested in target date funds. He was really part of the group that like helped make that uh a sort of like uh thing and so retirement funds being just in some some allocation of equities and stocks uh he has there's a group of people who are very diehard into this sort of like way of doing they call themselves bogel heads after after anyways uh so a deep rabbit hole for sort of investing but the little book of common sense investing comes with a lot of other sort of like
甚至15、20年前获得了多得多的关注。当时这还有点离经叛道。人们并没有那种会自动投资于目标日期基金（target date funds）的401(k)账户。他确实是帮助将这种模式推广为一种常规做法的群体之一，因此退休基金只需要按某种股票和资产配置来持有。有一群人非常狂热地崇拜这种做事方式，他们称自己为“伯格头”（Bogle heads），因杰克·伯格而得名。无论如何，这是一个通往投资领域的深不见底的兔子洞，但《共同基金常识小书》还带来了许多其他关于如何看待金钱的
ways of thinking about money i would say uh in addition to just sort of like the investing and savings but just the importance of that um there is a a bunch of rabbit trails to run down here without turning it into a finance podcast about uh just interest but i will say i was uh i saw some statistic the other day just talking about how much growth there has been in sort of broad index investing across the world but but in the united states we have something like the s&p 500 or the russell 2000 the biggest 500 by market cap companies and the amount of people investing just in all those 500 rather than not and they call this sort of passive where you
思考方式，我想，除了单纯的投资和储蓄之外，还有理解这一点的重中之重。这里有大把的支线话题可以深入探讨，虽然我们不打算把它变成一个纯粹的金融播客，只谈论利息，但我得说，我前几天看到一些统计数据，谈到了世界各地广泛的指数投资取得了多么巨大的增长，但在美国，我们有一些像标普500指数（S&P 500）或罗素2000指数（Russell 2000）这样的指数，涵盖了按市值计算最大的500家公司。而现在，人们选择投资于这全部500家公司，而不是其他个股，这种做法被称为被动投资，也就是你
just buy right don't care if it goes up or down you'll sell when you retire or you need the money but you're not trading the amount of passively invested money there's a lot of uh interesting debate about has this changed market dynamics is there like an end game where markets are somehow like messed up because it doesn't matter what your company reports as its earnings, like everybody's gonna still buy it because it's part of the S&P 500. There's a lot of debate about what sort of changing I won't get into sort of my thoughts there, the efficient market hypothesis, there's a lot of a lot of stuff around this. But anyways, a lot of folks listening, you know, early in your career or not, and sort of wondering of a way of thinking about how many you could do a
只管买入，不关心它上涨还是下跌，等你退休或需要用钱时再卖出，而不是频繁交易。关于被动投资资金的规模，引发了许多有趣的辩论：这是否改变了市场动态？是否存在这样一种终局：市场在某种程度上变得混乱了，因为一家公司的财报表现如何已经无关紧要了，反正每个人都还是会买它，因为它属于标普500指数的一部分？关于这种变化有着各种各样的辩论。我不会深入探讨我在这方面的想法、有效市场假说（efficient market hypothesis）等等，这周围有太多的内容了。不过无论如何，许多在听节目的朋友，无论你处于职业生涯的早期还是其他阶段，如果你想寻找一种关于如何对待财富的思考方式，那么去看
lot worse than picking up this book and sort of wondering of a way of thinking about how many you could do a lot worse than picking up this book and sort of thinking about just diversified holdings, not trading, just being really sort of straightforward, not making it over complicated. And this is this is sort of like the vast way of, I think, modeling how I think as well, to in part because of him and others in a similar vein. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, just a short story. If you don't diversify, if you take huge risk, you could potentially get huge reward, but you could also get completely wiped out. I know if you are going into industry and they're paying you in stock, then you're potentially going to end up with a lot of shares of stock of your company
这本书，你的选择绝对不会比这更糟糕了；去思考多元化持仓、拒绝频繁交易、保持真正直观而不把事情搞得过于复杂的方式。这也正是我大脑中思考方式的宏观体现，部分原因也是受到了他和同类理念的其他人的影响。是的，这说得通。我是说，讲个简短的故事：如果你不进行多元化投资，如果你承担巨大的风险，你可能会获得巨大的回报，但也完全有可能彻底破产。我知道，如果你进入某个行业，而他们用股票来支付你的薪水，那么你最终可能会持有大量你所效力的那家公司的股票。而且，你知道的，我听说过这样一些故事：有人说，“嘿，你知道的，我在同一家公司工作，我是最早的员工之一，我已经在那里呆了10年了，公司发展得太棒了。我从来没有卖掉过我的任何股票，然后它就爆发了。”那是因为他们承担了巨大的风险，并得到了巨大的回报。这很棒。但你未必会听到那些在公司工作过的人的故事——公司崛起，公司上市以便他们抛售股票，结果他们把所有股票都死死抓在手里。然后不可避免地在接下来的5年、10年、15年里，在未来的某个时间点，公司崩盘了，那个人失去了所有。这种情况发生的频率比我们作为一个社区所愿意承认的要高得多。而且那些故事并没有被放大，因为没有人愿意
that you already work at. And, you know, I've heard stories where people said, hey, you know, I've worked at the same company, you know, I was one of the first employees, I've been there for 10 years, the company's doing amazing. And I never sold any of my shares, and it just exploded. And that's because they took this huge risk, and they got this huge reward. And that's great. You don't necessarily hear the stories of the people who worked at companies, company rose up, the company went public so that they could sell their shares. They held on to everything. And then inevitably in the next five years, 10 years, 15 years, at the next point in time, at some point, the company collapses and that person loses everything. That does happen more often than as a community, we want to admit. And those stories aren't amplified because no one wants
那么做。所以你真的必须小心。是的，我和帕特里克看法一致。我认为，阅读某种类型的……你知道的，这感觉好像没多少内容，这里一点，那里一点，但当你年复一年地坚持这样做时，我认为这实际上也是一种哲学，我发现它反映在我对自己职业发展的思考方式上——我从不寻求……所以我们会看到现在随着大语言模型的出现，人们蜂拥而至，比如“我要成为一名提示词工程师，我要弄清楚如何使用这个”，或者我们在讨论“好吧，99%我要去弄清楚如何合成你的超级……”，好吧，但那是一种方式——我并不是说你不能这么做，它具有更大的离散性，你的结果也可能大相径庭，你可能会做得很好，但通常你可能不会，平均情况可能没那么
to do that. So you really have to be careful. And yeah, I'm with Patrick on this. I think, you know, reading some sort of you know it doesn't feel like much you know a little bit here a little bit there but then when you keep doing it year after year and i think it's actually a philosophy i feel mirrored and how i think about my career growth as well is just i'm never looking for like so i'd have this oh we see this now with large language models coming out people jumping on like oh i'm going to be a prompt engineer i'm going to figure out you know how to use you know this or we're talking about okay 99 i'm going to go like figure out how to synthesize your super okay but like that is a way i'm not saying you can't it it has a a more dispersion and sort of like your outcomes you might do really well often you probably won't the average case probably not
出色。但我感觉在你的职业生涯中，只要寻求逐年递增的进步，思考一下每年有哪些一两三件你可以做或学习的事情，来为你现有的技能添砖加瓦。我觉得这是一种在长达10年、20年、30年的职业生涯中，让你在最终能够变得非常非常优秀的方法，只要你只是在取得那种复合式的、渐进的进步。不过也许这是一个更宏大的……完全同意，完全同意。另外，为了顺着这个话题稍微即兴发挥一下，然后我们就会进入下一题，但……很多时候，这些白手起家的故事基本上都是胡扯。当你看到某种小东西变成真正巨大的东西时，实际上背后有非常大的、齐心协力的努力，才让那个小东西变得宏大。所以，皮特·蒂尔（Peter Thiel）提出了一个很好的观点：他基本上是说，如果你是一家大公司，你不想让自己看起来像个垄断企业，
that great but i feel like in your career just looking for incremental each year what's you know one two three things you can do or learn that add on to what you already have i feel like this is a way over the course of a career 10 20 30 years all right you can be really really good at stuff by the end if you're just making sort of compounding incremental progress but maybe that's a a broader totally agree totally agree also uh just just to riff on that a little bit and then we'll move on but um a lot of the times these like rags to riches stories are kind of bs and and and when you see something small turn into something really big there actually was a really big concerted effort to make that small thing big and so you know actually a good way peter teal puts a pretty good way he basically says if you're a big company you want to not seem like a monopoly
因为你不想被拆分；而如果你是一家小公司，你想让自己看起来非常大，因为你想让投资者感到非常兴奋。这就产生了一种非常奇怪的抛物线效应。因此，许多……许多小公司实际上可能得到了来自外部的大量推动，它们并没有那么小。这就会给你留下这样的印象：是的，你可以在地下室里创办一家价值数十亿美元的公司。但当你真正深入挖掘细节时，很多时候从第一天起就有巨大的机构支持。好吧，我们要进入我的……所以帕特里克，我是为你准备这个的。是的，我看到了，我很兴奋，我们开始吧。好。所以，我决定阅读更多的虚构小说。我的儿子——基本上事情是这样的：我儿子第二次读完了《哈利·波特》。
because you don't want to get broken up and if you're a small company you want to seem really big because you want the investors to get really excited and so it creates this really weird parabolic effect um and so a lot of a lot of uh um a lot of of small companies actually maybe had a lot of of push from the outside and they weren't actually that small and so i give you the impression that like yeah in your basement you could start x billion dollar company but but when you actually dig into the details a lot of the time there's like huge institutional backing even from day one um all right we'll move to my so patrick i did this for you um yeah i see this i'm excited let. Let's go. Yeah. So I decided to read more fiction. My son, basically the way this happened, my son finished Harry Potter the second time.
他读了它，看了两遍。然后我的一个同事推荐了布兰登·桑德森（Brandon Sanderson），因为他有一本书。那是谁？我想它叫《天空远征》（Skyward），是写给孩子们看的。是的。所以我读了那本书，心想：“你知道，我真的应该读更多虚构小说。我读了所有这些编程书，读了一些经济学书、哲学书，你知道的，我只是需要一些轻松一点的内容，
He read it, threw it twice. And one of my coworkers suggested Brandon Sanderson because he has a book. Who's that? I think it's called Skyward, the one for kids. Yes. And so I did that and I thought, you know, I really should read more fiction. I read all these programming books. I read some economics books, philosophy books, you know, and I just need something lighter,
尤其是我知道自己在过去几个月里要经常坐飞机。”于是我开始看《迷雾之子》（Mistborn）三部曲，这太棒了。我是它的超级粉丝。我记得你多年前谈过这个，并且不想剧透，但……为了回顾帕特里克多年前说过的话，书里有一些人可以通过某种非常神奇的方式操纵金属，并且……由那个单一构思衍生出了各种各样的事情。我想我才刚读完第二本，大约读到一半。所以，我仍然不太明白为什么——
especially I knew I was going to be on an airplane a bunch the past couple of months. And so I got into the Mistborn saga and it is awesome. I am a big fan. I remember you talking about this years ago and not wanting to spoil it but but uh just to recap what Patrick said many years ago there's people who can manipulate metal um in a way that's really magical and um there's all sorts of uh things that that that are spun off from that one idea. And I think I've only finished, I'm about halfway through the second book. So I still don't quite understand why.
我是说，我在这里没有剧透任何东西——你知道的，为什么到处都是火山灰？究竟是什么导致地球遭到这样的破坏？我还没有揭开这些秘密，但我已经读了一本半了，我真的非常兴奋，而且……这是我一直非常喜欢的东西，所以重新回到虚构小说中感觉真不错，我想我会继续读下去。是的，它们……而且现在，你知道的，这是最初的三部曲，但现在还有一些故事发生在三部曲之后的新书籍。所以你实际上前方有很长的后续内容要读。既然你已经进入了
I mean, I'm not spoiling anything here. You know, why there's ash all over the place. Like what actually caused the earth to be destroyed like this? Like I haven't uncovered any of these secrets yet, but I'm a book of an and a half in i'm i'm really uh excited and uh it's um it's something that uh i've been really enjoying so so it feels good to get back into fiction i think i'm going to keep it up yeah they and now like you know this is the original trilogy but then there's also now like additional books that are set after the that trilogy but then there's also now like additional books that are set after the that trilogy so you actually have a lot of runway ahead of you uh and then now that
布兰登·桑德森的这种风格，你会发现他在这里应用的体系实际上是元体系的一部分。就像金属在这里的运作方式，类似于他的书的世界中其他地方的其他东西的运作方式，可以说。因此，对金属的处理在某种程度上是由其他系列中的其他东西所掌控的，并且各个系列之间也存在着交织，它们并不是完全孤立的。所以，是的，为了大致铺垫一下背景，让你浅尝辄止，而不是被吓退，你可以继续从你现在所处的位置向外不断螺旋式深入。不过，是的，我是说前几本，其中一些带有怀旧色彩，你几乎会怀念并想要重回那种最初的
you're in the uh brian's that brandon sanderson like thing you'll find out that the system he's applied here is actually part of a meta system so like the way that metals sort of work here is similar to how other things let's just say work in other locations in the universe of his books and so the there's a treatment of metal in sort of this that is handled by other things in other series and so and there are sort of like intertwinings between the series as well they're not completely isolated so um yeah just to kind of like set the stage like to dip your toe and then not to get scared but like yeah you can keep spiraling further and further out from uh from where you are but yeah i mean those first ones it's some of those nostalgia like you almost miss miss going back and like that first kind of
“哦，这太疯狂了，太酷了”的感觉。是的，我记得，这些书很不错。他们曾试图把它做成电子游戏，我想，但我相信已经停滞不研发了。我……是的，我想它已经停滞不前了。哦，对了，我以为……我以为这是一种很巧妙的说法，基本上就像是想象整个元素周期表的这一部分是被禁止涉足的。这就像是一种很奇怪的想法，但它作为构建宇宙的基础前提却非常棒。你知道的，这真的很……因为，
like oh what that's just so crazy and it's so cool yeah i remember it's those are good they tried to make it into a video game i think but i believe it's stalled out i yeah i think it's stalled out yeah oh yeah i thought um um i thought that was a clever way of saying it basically like imagine if this whole section of the periodic table was like off limits it's like kind of like a weird thing to think about, but it's like a good premise behind building a universe. You know, it's really because it's,
你知道的，我尽量回避的东西之一，就是那些过于未来的东西，比如《星球大战》。这并不是我对它有什么冷漠，或者……不是冷漠，而是任何……
you know, one thing that, that I try to shy away from are things that are like futuristic, like star Wars. And it's not that I do, I have any apathy to that or, or not an apathy, but any,
这确实是冷漠。当它开始涉及激光束、宇宙飞船之类的内容时，我只是……它无法以同样的方式吸引我。但在这里，你知道的，它对我来说足够真实，以至于我能在脑海中想象出它的画面，而且……我最后可能也会去涉猎那些太空书。我知道有《天空远征》和所有这些太空作品，我最终可能会去读它们，主要……好吧，
it is really apathy. Like when it starts getting into laser beams and spaceships and stuff i just it just not doesn't really kind of engage me the same way but here it was you know it was real enough for me that i could kind of see it in my in my mind's eye and uh um i might end up getting into the into the i know that that there's skyward and all these space ones i might end up getting into them, into the, I know that, that there's Skyward and all these space ones. I might end up getting into them mostly. Well,
我很兴奋。你得让我们随时了解最新情况。是的，完全同意。我一直在跳到“本周工具”环节。我一直在我的Remarkable上阅读，我对它非常满意。你……
I'm excited. You have to keep us up to date. Yeah, totally. And I've been jumping into tool of the show. I've been reading this on my remarkable, which I've been really happy with. Do you,
你有其中一个吗，帕特里克？我没有。我没有。我没有。所以，我一直想要……我以前有一本写满笔记的记事本，我经常在不同的笔记之间翻来翻去。我基本上在这本书里为我团队中的每个人留了一页，我还为不同的主题留了页。所以，你知道的，如果有人说了我需要告诉别人的话，我就会翻到书中的那一页。
do you have one of these Patrick? I do not. I do not. I do not. So I, I've been wanting, I had a composition have one of these patrick i do not i do not i do not so i i've been wanting i had a composition book full of notes and i'm constantly flipping among different notes i had basically a page in this book for each person on my team i had pages for different topics and so you know if someone would say something that i would need to tell someone else i would flip to that page in the book.
在当今时代，这样做感觉有点傻。但我使用这种记事本的原因是，书写的动作确实帮助我记忆。不仅能记住内容，还能记住那一页上有我需要处理的事情。而且我还可以翻回去把事情划掉——我知道你在谷歌文档（Google Doc）里也能做到这一点，但我只是发现书写的部分真的非常非常有用。所以我想我会买一个这种做笔记的平板电脑——有很多选择，有Kobo，亚马逊也有Scribe，看起来很不错。我最终选择了Remarkable，因为它是几个同事推荐给我的。而且我认为它很棒。
And it just felt kind of silly in today's day and age to be doing that. But the reason I was using a composition book was that the act of writing really helped me remember. Not only remember the content, but remember that there is something on that page that I need to take care of. And also I could go back through and cross things out which I know you could do that at google doc but um I just found the writing part really really useful so so I thought I would get one of these kind of uh note-taking tablets um there's a bunch of options there's a books there's uh amazon has a scribe which looks pretty good I settled on the remarkable because I was it was recommended by a couple of coworkers. And I think it's great.
你可以在上面读书。你可以在上面做笔记。它还有一些其他功能，比如OCR（光学字符识别）之类的，我其实没觉得那些功能有多大用处。但核心功能极其出色。我通常不是那种对时尚感、现代小玩意儿之类感兴趣的人，但我得说，当我在飞机上掏出Remarkable时，坐在两边的人都印象深刻。它有点像一个非常大的Kindle，但它的制造工艺极其精良。
You can read books on it. You could take notes with it. It has some other features like OCR and stuff, which I haven't really found them that useful. But the core functionality is extremely nice. And I'm usually not one of these people who has any type of fashion sense or any modern gadgets or anything like that. But I will say when I pulled out the Remarkable on the plane, the people who sat on either side were very impressed. It is kind of like a very large Kindle, but it's extremely well manufactured.
它非常薄。对比度极好。而且，是的，我强烈推荐它。所以是电子墨水屏，对吧？哦，对，我们应该谈谈这一点。所以它是电子墨水屏，这意味着——我想它的工作原理是：以某种频率注入一些电流，这会指示墨水显现或隐藏，这是按像素发生的。所以这意味着它需要一点时间，比如你可以滚动，但当你滚动时，它的滚动速度大约是
It's very thin. The contrast is extremely nice. And yeah, I would highly recommend it. So e-ink, right? Oh yeah, we should talk about that. So it's e-ink, which means, I think the way it works is some electricity is forced in a certain frequency and that tells the ink to reveal itself or not and that happens per pixel and so that means is like it takes a little while so like for example you can scroll but when you scroll it's scrolling at
每秒半帧左右，所以感觉有点奇怪。它更适合像翻书那样一页一页地翻阅。不过它的好处在于，电池基本上能用几个月。而且，当你什么都不做时，它不消耗任何能量。事实上，如果你把它放在那里30分钟不管，它就会关闭Wi-Fi，关闭处理器，基本上彻底进入休眠状态，不消耗任何能量，但你仍然保留着整个屏幕——30分钟前你看的任何内容都还在那里，它只是在旁边放了一个小图标，说明它正在休眠。所以，是的，我极少需要考虑给它充电，而且，是的，我在上面读了整本书，只用了5%的电池。所以，是的，这是一个好产品。我要说的是亚马逊的Scribe带有背光，
like half a frame a second or something and so it's kind of a weird feeling. It makes much more sense like flip page to page. But then the nice thing about it is, is the battery lasts for basically months. And, and while you're not doing anything, it's not using any energy. And in fact, if you leave it for 30 minutes, it will turn off the Wi Fi, turn off the processor basically totally go to sleep and not use any energy but you still have the whole screen like whatever you were looking at 30 minutes ago is still there um it just put a little icon next to it saying it's asleep um so yeah i mean i rarely have to think about charging it and uh yeah i read whole books on it and used like 5% of the battery. So yeah, it's a good product. I will say the Amazon Scribe has backlighting.
而这款没有。所以在飞机上这没问题，因为你有头顶的阅读灯。但如果你没有一盏灯在旁边，你晚上就没法用它。现在，想象一下，如果你同时拥有Remarkable和LK-99，想象一下那电池——就像我开始用它时电量是50%，然后我不得不把它关掉，因为它被你的手烫得过热了。好吧，我本周推荐的工具是Stellarium，我想这就是它的发音，但更广泛地说，有一类……我会说是某种天文类的应用程序。我一直有这样一种情结：我从来不是天文迷，我不知道你们俩以前是不是这样，杰克、比利，我曾经拥有过一台望远镜，
This one doesn't. And so for an airplane, that's fine because you have the overhead light. But you can't use this at night without having a light next to you. Now, just imagine if you had a remarkable and lk99 just imagine the battery it's like i start using it at 50 and then i have to turn it off because it overheats from your hand yeah all right my tool of the show is stellarium i think that's how you say it but but just more broadly there's a the class of uh i'll say sort of astronomy apps i've always had this thing like i was never big into astronomy i don't know if you ever were jason billy i had a telescope once
但我从没用好过它。所以我开始重新对它产生兴趣。我想这是我第一次拥有智能手机时下载的那些应用之一，你可以把手机指向夜空，它就会告诉你，你知道这是什么？哦，是的。我还在用那个。是的。不是通过图像识别，
but i was never very good at it uh so i started to get interested in it again and i one of those things i think i downloaded when i first got a smartphone where you like point your phone up in the night sky and it tells you, you know what? Oh yeah. I still use that. Yeah. Not by image recognition,
而是纯粹通过指南针、加速度计和理解空间姿态。但它们只是……我不知道，就像我继续使用它一样，我感觉我用过之后就会觉得：“哦，这其实真的很酷。”
but just by like compass and accelerometers and understanding pose. But they just, I don't know. Like, I guess I just continued to work on it and I feel like I used it and it's just like, Oh, this is actually really cool.
而且还能知道……什么时候能看到我想看的东西？我想向我的孩子们展示木星之类的，对吧？就像：哦，
And then also being able to know like, when is something I want to see, I want to show my kids Jupiter or whatever, right? Like, Oh know like when is something i want to see i want to show my kids jupiter or whatever right like oh well when is jupiter going to be in the sky and just like having it's just very cool and i was uh i'm trying to gonna try it's been really cloudy here so i got this idea that i'm like i'm gonna do this i had an old telescope i got out and like then it's been cloudy every night so it hasn't worked yet but i haven't been taking this still airing out and like trying to look up and like imagine what the stars would be uh and uh you know
木星什么时候会出现在天空中？拥有这个功能非常酷。而且我正试图……这里的天气一直很多云，所以我有了这个主意，心想：我要用这个。我有一台旧望远镜拿出来了，然后结果每天晚上都是多云，所以还没用成。不过我一直在带着这个Stellarium出门，试图抬头仰望，想象星星会是什么样子。
it's just pretty exciting one of those things i kind of forgot existed even though i mean i guess probably lots of people will use it i think most of these are free solarium as others are free to download they i think they charge you for like additional entries in the star database or, you know, if you want to search for certain things or do predictions about, I guess they're not really predictions, understand when something is going to occur. But in general,
这相当令人兴奋，这是那种我几乎忘记它存在的工具，尽管我觉得很多人可能都会用它。我认为这些软件大都是免费的，Stellarium和其他应用一样可以免费下载。我想他们会对星空数据库中的附加条目收费，或者如果你想搜索某些东西，或者预测……我想其实不是预测，而是了解某个事件何时会发生。但总的来说，
you can normally use them and poke around them for free, which is, which is pretty cool. So if you've never tried that before and you have a smartphone, which probably do, if you're listening to this, then I would recommend, recommend checking it out.
你通常可以免费使用它们并到处探索，这相当酷。所以如果你以前从未尝试过，而且你有一部智能手机（如果你在听这个节目，你很可能有一部），那么我建议你去看一看。
Yeah. I mean, I had my first moment where I felt like my son who's 10 is like just light years ahead of me in something. And he's really into science, all kinds of science, biology, astronomy. He's constantly reading books on it. And I was pointed to this star that was really bright and he goes oh yeah he's looking around the sky he's like i'm pretty sure it's venus and i thought you know a 10 year old's
是的。我是说，我有过这样一个时刻，当时我觉得我10岁的儿子在某些方面简直领先我光年。他对科学非常热衷，各种科学，生物学、天文学。他一直在阅读这方面的书。我指着一颗非常亮的星星，他走过来——哦，是的，他环顾天空，说道：“我敢肯定是金星。”我想，你知道的，10岁的孩子
like they're just making stuff up all the time right so i pulled out i don't know if i'm using the same app as you but i pulled out one of these apps and it was venus and like it totally blew my mind um but uh but yeah that stuff is is super super fun it's a great time if you're ever watching fireworks or ever in a situation where you're out at night it's really fun to pull that out and see all the constellations and everything yeah i when it has all the constellations on there i'm just like oh yeah it turns out i don't know anything about any of this if you had pointed out a bit like be like, yeah, star. And then I wouldn't have been wrong. Oh, man.
总是随时在瞎编乱造，对吧？所以我掏出——我不知道我用的是不是和你一样的应用——我掏出其中一个应用，结果发现那就是金星，这彻底震撼了我的世界。但……但，是的，这些东西超级超级有趣。如果你在看烟花，或者身处夜晚户外的任何情况下，掏出它来查看所有的星座和一切，真的非常有趣。是的，当它显示出所有的星座时，我只想说：“哦，原来我对手头这些东西一无所知。”如果你之前随便指着一颗星并说：“对，那是颗星星。”那我也不会错。天哪。
All right. On to the topic of recursion. The scariest topic for every first or second year CS student. No. I mean, not for me either. But I think that in aggregate, people got more scared about recursion than anything else. And I think, you know, we're going to jump around a little bit in the notes, but I think the reason why it was scary is because the way that it was taught, at least at my university, which as we know from LinkedIn is a crap university. I actually love my university.
好吧，进入递归（recursion）的主题。每个计算机科学专业大一或大二学生的噩梦。不。我是说，对我来说也不是。但我觉得总体而言，人们对递归的恐惧超过了其他任何东西。而且我认为，我们在笔记里会稍微跳来跳去，但我觉得它之所以可怕，是因为它的教授方式——至少在我所在的大学是这样，而正如我们从领英上了解到的那样，那是一所烂大学。其实我很爱我的大学。
I went to UCF, University of Central Florida. I loved loved it there it's a great school for CS but they're kind of being the butt of today's episode so you know people were taught sorting right and so sorting it's kind of like this tool like you immediately see how it's useful like you could see I have a list of things and I have a sorted list of things. It makes sense. And then they're taught structures like, uh, you know, a linked list and, uh,
我去了中佛罗里达大学（UCF，University of Central Florida）。我非常热爱那里，对于计算机科学来说它是一所很棒的学校，但它们在今天的节目里有点成了靶子。所以，你知道的，人们被教导排序，对吧？排序就像是这样一种工具，你立刻就能看出它的用处，因为你可以看到：我有一个无序的列表，我有一个有序的列表。这说得通。然后他们被教导各种结构，比如链表，以及
uh, you know, what's another entry level structure, maybe a binary tree. Yeah. It's just like, okay, these are structures and I don't really know how they're useful yet,
……另一个入门级结构是什么，也许是二叉树。是的，就像是：好吧，这些是结构，我虽然还不太清楚它们有什么用，
but, but, but, but, you know, it's like, I could see the structure and the geometry of it and understand it right. And then recursion, it's kind of like they're trying to fit that mold to teach recursion and it never really works.
但……但……但，你知道的，就像我能看到这个结构及其几何形状并理解它一样。然后是递归，他们似乎试图把这种模式套用到教学中，但却从未真正奏效。
So what will usually happen is they'll say, well, you know, the one I think they use is the making change. So they're like, OK, in the American system system you can greedily make change where you just give people as many quarters like let's say you need 74 cents in change i just give you quarters until it's less than 25 and then i give you dimes until it's less than 10 and we just keep going right but what if there's this crazy you know coin system where like there's a seven cent coin and a three cent coin and a one cent if i give you the seven cent i can't give you the three cent and yeah i mean i guess patrick's like head is exploding right now well no they taught you the knapsack problem as like an introduction to recursion
所以通常发生的情况是，他们会说，好吧，我认为他们用的例子是找零钱。所以他们会说，OK，在美国货币系统中，你可以用贪心算法来找零，也就是你给别人尽可能多的25美分硬币——比方说你需要找74美分零钱，我一直给你25美分，直到凑够的钱小于25美分，然后我给你10美分硬币，直到小于10美分，我们一直这样下去，对吧？但如果存在某种疯狂的……你知道的，硬币系统，比如有7美分硬币、3美分硬币和1美分硬币，如果我给了你7美分，我就不能给你3美分……是的，我是说，我猜帕特里克的脑袋现在都要爆炸了。不，他们把背包问题（knapsack problem）当作递归的入门教学。
that's very brutal yeah and it's like you know here's how you make change with you know and here's here's why you can't do it the normal way because you're not in normal currency and the whole thing was just like didn't make any sense right and it didn't really relate to other stuff i feel like um i think the reason they do this is if they were to connect it to other things and you didn't grasp those other things now you're just kind of falling even further behind right so if they said well here's recursion and how it applies to sorting but like the kids didn't understand sorting that well it's like then you know they kind of totally lose them but uh i guess in general maybe to step back a bit recursion just wasn't in general i feel like isn't taught very well and that's what makes it so scary to so many people i would agree i wasn't taught that like to be clear the problem you're introducing is
那太残酷了。就像是：这就是你如何用这种硬币找零的方法，这就是为什么你不能用正常方式找零的原因，因为你不在正常的货币系统里。整个事情就完全讲不通，对吧？而且我觉得它跟其他东西也没有什么关联。我想他们这么做的原因，是如果他们把它联系到其他东西上，而你没有掌握那些其他东西，你现在就会进一步落后，对吧？所以如果他们说：“好吧，这就是递归以及它如何应用于排序”，但孩子们对排序根本没那么理解，那么……你知道的，他们就会彻底听不懂。不过，我想总的来说，退一步讲，递归总体上没有被教好，这就是为什么它对这么多人来说如此可怕。我同意。我当时学的时候可不是这样的——需要明确的是，你引入的这个
this is pretty difficult so we were taught it with i think you you uh you probably encountered as well but how to calculate the fibonacci sequence uh which for me was demotivating in a different way which is it was such an obviously horrible way of computing the Fibonacci sequence. Like it is not a, like that is like not the way as someone who I guess started in like a more optimization C like low level coding way. As soon as you tell me that you're going to like,
问题相当困难。所以我们学递归时，我想你大概也遇到过，是用它来计算斐波那契数列（Fibonacci sequence）。这对我来说是以一种不同的方式消磨了积极性：计算斐波那契数列的方法显然太糟糕了。这根本不是一个……作为一个大概从更偏向优化、C语言这种底层编码方式起步的人，一旦你告诉我你要去……
I understand what you're talking about with recursion. And then I'm like, no, you do not want to do this. This is not very efficient. And so it bothered me for a different way i think though you're right i think this is not a it is a natural phenomenon but not in a sort of like intuitive way you would encounter perhaps before you would be encountering this so if you've not encountered fractals or self similarity before this idea that you have a function and inside that function is an
我理解你在递归方面谈论的内容。然后我会想：不，你绝对不想这么做。这效率一点也不高。所以它从另一个方面困扰了我。不过我想你是对的，我认为这不是一个自然现象，或者说不是那种在你接触之前可能会遇到的直观现象。所以如果你以前没有接触过分形或自相似性（self similarity），这种“你有一个函数，而在这个函数内部是对该函数本身的调用”的想法——这种自相似性、递归性，并不是你在数学中会被介绍的内容，尽管它在数学中确实存在。你可能不会在你当时所学的数学课中看到它，除非你在大学生涯的非常后期才转入计算机科学。所以当你接触到这种概念时，就像是：“嘿，我们等会儿会讨论这个，但——嘿，你将会无限地向下、向下、向下、向下递归，或者一路分叉下去。”你开始在大脑中形成一个非常难懂的模型，因为这不再是那种迭代式的、
invocation of the function itself this like self-similarity self the recursive isn't something you would be have been introduced to in math although it does exist in math you would probably not have seen it in the math you would have taken at that time unless you moved to computer science very late in your college career and so i think approaching this like hey and we're going to talk about in a minute but like hey you're going to just infinitely go down and down and down and down or forking all your way down you just start to get this mental model that's very difficult because it's not this sort of iterative uh you know imperative way of programming anymore in fact right like functional programming
命令式的编程方式了。事实上，对吧，函数式编程本身就和这种命令式编程有很大的相似之处，所以你认为你会得到很多这样的联系。然后还有出错的情况：当你搞砸了你的终止条件时，你的程序就会崩溃，而且它崩溃时不会给出好的错误提示，它会以“内存溢出”的形式崩溃。对于那些在Java中而不是在已经遇到过1000次内存泄漏的C或C++中编程的人来说，你可能会想：“噢天哪，这到底是怎么回事？这是什么意思？”对吧？就像你面对的是一万页的堆栈轨迹（stack trace）之类的信息。是的，完全没错。当你的程序崩溃时，你得不到有用的调试信息。而当你试图打印出某些东西时，就像杰克所说的那样，
itself it bears a lot of semblance this versus imperative programming so you think you get a lot of those ties and then also the failure case when you mess up your sort of end condition is your program crashes and it doesn't crash with like a good error it crashes like out of memory which for you know if you're in j Java and not sort of C or C++, where you've already encountered 1000 memory leaks, you're probably like, Oh my gosh, like, what is going on? Like, what does this mean? Right? Like you're like a 10,000 pages of a stack trace or something. Yeah, exactly. Like, you're not getting useful debugging information when your program crashes. And when you try to print something like jason is saying
你只会立刻得到成页成页的日志，直到你的堆栈溢出，然后程序崩溃。因此，至少在我熟悉并在大学或高中被教授的绝大多数语言中，与递归的交互……这是一段糟糕的体验。是的，这非常合乎情理。你知道的，这是一个非常、非常、非常好的观点：这里没有一个能够追踪堆栈的打印函数。没有一个打印函数会说：“好吧，这是这个变量，这是父函数中的同名变量，这是父函数的父函数，一直追溯到这个函数的根调用。”你无法在一行中看到所有这些，除非你将这一点构建到你的程序中，而这并不是一件微不足道的事。所以你是对的，你正在……
you just immediately get like you know pages and pages of logs until your stack overflows and then you crash so the like interaction with recursion at least in most of the languages that i'm familiar with being taught in college uh is or high school uh it's a bad experience yeah that makes a ton of sense you know it's um um it's a really really really good point that there isn't a print function which like keeps track of the stack there isn't a print function that's like like okay here's this variable and here's the same variable you know in the parent function and the parent of the parent all the way to the root call of this function you can't see that all on one line unless you you know build that into your program which is not trivial um and so you're right what you're
你马上就会得到，你知道的，几页几页的日志，直到你的堆栈溢出然后程序崩溃，所以至少在我熟悉并在大学或高中教授的大多数语言中，与递归的交互是一种糟糕的体验，是的，这非常合乎情理，你知道的，这是一个非常非常好的观点，那就是没有一个能追踪堆栈的打印函数，没有一个打印函数能像这样：好吧，这里是这个变量，这里是父函数中的同一个变量，以及一直到这个函数根调用的父函数的父函数，除非你把它写进你的程序里（这并不是微不足道的），否则你无法把这些都在同一行里看到，所以你是对的，你刚刚
looking at is you know i see all of these prints and they're all from different invocations imagine like the fibonacci sequence and maybe i'll take a little bit of time to cover what that is so i think it's f of x minus two plus f of x minus one something like that yeah okay so fibonacci sequence um so there's it's it's a function of x x has to be an integer and so it's a discrete function and f of zero is is one, f of one is one. So those are your base cases, right? But then f of two is going to be f of zero plus f of one. So in this case, it's going to be two. f of three is f of one plus f of two, right? f of one is one and f two, we just calculate as two. So f of three 3 is 3 but then you can kind of imagine
我们正在看的是，你知道，我看到了所有这些打印输出，它们都来自不同的调用。想象一下，比如斐波那契数列，也许我会花一点时间来介绍那是什么。所以我想它是 f(x 减 2) 加上 f(x 减 1)，大概是这样，对，好的。所以斐波那契数列，嗯，所以它是一个关于 x 的函数，x 必须是一个整数，所以它是一个离散函数。f(0) 是 1，f(1) 是 1。所以这些是你的基本情况，对吧？但是然后 f(2) 将会是 f(0) 加上 f(1)。所以在这种情况下，它将是 2。f(3) 是 f(1) 加上 f(2)，对吧？f(1) 是 1，而 f(2) 我们刚计算出是 2。所以 f(3) 是 3，但随后你可以想象一下
how this is going to start growing really quickly because you know you're adding these numbers that they themselves are getting larger and larger and so it grows in probably some kind of quadratic way or exponential way um and so if you want for example f of 100 then that is f of 99 plus f of 98 now if you've already computed those in the past then that's fine but if not you know you have to compute those which means now you have to call two more functions for each of them and you can see it turns into this this binary tree and all the leaves of this tree are going to be either f of zero or f of one but as you kind of climb up this tree you're getting larger f values and you're getting a lot of repetition you could potentially be calculating f of four you know thousands and thousands of times to get to f of
这个东西将如何开始增长得非常快，因为你知道你在把这些数字相加，而它们本身变得越来越大，所以它可能以某种二次方或指数的方式增长，嗯，如果你想要例如 f(100)，那么这就是 f(99) 加上 f(98)。现在，如果你以前已经计算过那些，那没问题，但如果没有，你知道，你必须计算它们，这意味着现在你必须为它们中的每一个调用另外两个函数，你可以看到它变成了这个二叉树，而这棵树的所有叶子节点要么是 f(0)，要么是 f(1)。但当你爬上这棵树时，你会得到更大的 f 值，并且你会得到大量的重复，你可能会计算 f(4)，你知道，成千上万次，为了得到 f 的
100 um and uh uh you know and once you finish you know uh you know computing this whole tree then you get your answer but you know depending on how you write the recursion, you're kind of going through this tree in kind of different orders that might not be very natural. And so if you think you have some error in your Fibonacci function and you put a print, that print's going to give you all kinds of different numbers from all kinds of different numbers from all kinds of different
100，嗯，并且，嗯，你知道，一旦你完成，你知道，计算完整棵树，然后你就会得到你的答案，但是你知道，取决于你如何编写递归，你以某种可能不是很自然的各种顺序遍历这棵树。所以如果你认为你的斐波那契函数有某种错误，并且你放了一个打印语句，那个打印语句会给你来自各种各样上下文的各种各样的数字，而且很难调试。我的意思是，我不是老师，也不是学者，所以我没有尝试过教递归、斐波那契数列、背包问题，我不知道，我想也许我们谈过排序。我想实际上尝试教像二分查找或归并排序这样的东西——这不是我最初遇到它的方式，而是你实际上有一个固定长度的列表，这能在一定程度上限制问题，对吧？如果你弄砸了索引，一个简单的打印语句会告诉你，你要么重复了一个索引，要么你的下界和上界颠倒了——一些非常简单的侦探工作就会向你揭示你遇到了这个问题
contexts and it's very hard to debug i mean i'm not a teacher and i'm not an academic so i've not attempted to teach recursion fibonacci sequence knapsack prompt i don't know i think maybe we talked about sorting i think actually attempting to teach something like a binary search or a merge sort which is not how i first encountered it but where you have actually like a binary search or a merge sort which is not how i first encountered it but where you have actually like a fixed length list bounds the problem a bit right where if you screw up your indexes a simple print statement would sort of tell you you're either repeating an index or you have like your lower bound is flipped with your upper like some very simple detective work would sort of reveal to you that you've encountered this
问题，我认为探索一棵树或所有可能性——这有点像背包问题和斐波那契数列——在心理上感觉比这种“分治法”迈出了更大的一步，对吧？就像我把某样东西分成更小的部分，尽管我想这有点像同一回事，但它是一个量化的、非常量化的东西，对吧？就像我有一个包含八个整数的列表，然后我有两个包含四个整数的列表，然后是四个包含两个整数的列表。我又要搞砸了，我一直在这么做。无论如何，所以我觉得这是一个更——我不会说直观，也许对某些人来说不是，但我觉得那是教递归的另一个部分，就是用
problem and i think the exploration of a tree or of all possibilities which is sort of the knapsack problem and the fibonacci sequence feels like mentally more of a a large step than this sort of uh divide and conquer right like i'm splitting something into smaller pieces and even though i guess it's kind of the same thing it's a quantized very quantized thing right like i have a list of eight integers and then i have two lists of four and then four lists of two i'm gonna mess it up i keep doing this anyways and so i feel like this is a more i don't say intuitive maybe for some it's not but i feel like uh that is the other like piece of teaching the the recursive is using
它来进行排序和二分查找，我们甚至还没开始讨论树或这个，但我感觉那个设置，也许，某种程度上排序本身——为什么排序列表会从归并排序中涌现出来——可能有点难以掌握，但它那种像操作一样的小片段非常有意义。是的，我想你是对的，我认为他们使用斐波那契和背包问题的原因是因为，你知道，如果你在做，比如树搜索，那么你根本不需要任何记忆化，对吧？因为你看某样东西一次，如果你得到了答案就完成了，如果没有，那就没什么好真正记住的，因为你再也不会回来了。所以他们试图同时教授，你知道，递归、记忆化，以及最终像那种，我不知道你怎么称呼它，非递归（agglometric）的
it for sorting and binary search and and we're not even getting into trees or this just yet but i feel like that setup maybe maybe sort of the sorting itself like why a sorted list emerges from merge sort is a bit harder to grasp maybe but the sort of like operational bit of it makes a lot of sense yeah i think you're right i think you know the reason why they use fibonacci and knapsack problem is because you know if you're doing um like a tree search then you don't need any memoization right because you look at something once and if you got your answer you're done and you didn't, then there's nothing to really remember because you're never coming back. And so they try to teach, you know, recursion, memoization, and the ultimately like the sort of, I don't know what you call it, agglometric way of doing
做递归的方法。所以我来解释一下那是什么意思，所以斐波那契数，对吧，我们刚才谈到，如果你有 f(3)，它是 f(1) 加上 f(2)，但 f(2) 是 f(0) 加上 f(1)，所以你看 f(1) 在那里出现了两次，你需要它来求 f(2)，但然后你还需要它来求 f(3)，所以你知道，如果 f(1) 的计算成本非常高，那么你就要支付两次这个代价，对吧？所以你可以做一件事叫做记忆化（memoization），你可以说，嗯，我要从 f(100) 开始，嗯，当我计算 f(98) 时，我要把它存储在某个地方，在全局内存中，在计算机的某个地方，就像我计算了 f(98)，不管它是什么，是一兆还是什么的，我要把它存储在
recursion all at the same time. So I'll explain what that means so so fibonacci numbers right we just talked about if you have f of three it's f of one plus f of two but f of two is f of zero plus f of one so you see f of one is there twice you need it for f of two but then you also need it for f of three and so you know if f of one was really expensive to compute then you're paying that cost twice right so you could do something called memoization you can say well i'm going to start with f of 100 um and when i compute f of 98 um i'm going to store that somewhere just in global memory somewhere on the computer it's like i computed f of 98 it's whatever it is a zillion whatever um and i'm going to store that
表格的某个地方。然后当我去计算 f(99) 并且它需要 f(98) 时，我就去我的表格里把它取出来。我不需要计算 f(98) 超过一次，因为我知道没有副作用，每次我计算这个函数时，每次 98 进来，都会出来完全相同的数字。所以如果我能只把这个存起来，那么，嗯，那么对于 f(100) 我就只需要计算 100 个东西，因为即使我调用 f(98) 两次，我也只计算它一次。这为你需要做的工作量提供了一个非常好的界限。而在斐波那契数列的情况下，你知道，用朴素的方法在计算机上计算 f(100) 实际上可能需要一段时间。但只要你做了这个记忆化，它就从需要几秒钟甚至
in a table somewhere then when i go to compute f of 99 and it needs f of 98 i just go to my table and fetch it i don't have to compute f of 98 more than once because i know there's no side effects every time i compute this function every time a 98 comes in exactly the same number is going to come out so if i could just store this then uh uh then i would only have to for f of 100 i'd only have to compute 100 things because even if i'm calling f of 98 twice, I'm only computing it once. And so that gives you a really nice bound on how much work you're going to need to do. And in the case of Fibonacci sequence, you know, f of 100 could actually take a while on a computer doing it the naive way. But as soon as you do this memoization, it goes from taking seconds or even
几分钟，变成只需要，你知道，我不知道，80 纳秒左右，或者类似一个疯狂的短时间，嗯，然后你可以对自己说，好吧，嗯，我仍然要处理整个递归的事情，以及调用栈，以及调用，如果我甚至只是在做，如果我做 f(比方说)十万，我需要我的递归深度至少达到十万层，即使有了记忆化。对吧。所以也许我的计算机处理不了这个。那么如果我转而做一点不同的事情呢？如果我说，好吧，f(0) 是 0，f 的，或者抱歉，1，f(1) 是 1，嗯，并且我已经有了那些，那些在我的表格里，假设我先把那些放进去。那么现在 f(2) 是什么？嗯，我不需要做任何递归，因为我知道任何小于 2 的东西都已经计算过了，所以我
minutes to like taking you know i don't know 80 nanoseconds or something like an insanely short amount of time um then you can say to yourself okay well you know i still have to deal with like the whole recursion thing and the call stack and calling and what happens if i even just doing, if I do F of let's say a hundred thousand, I need my recursion limit to go at least a hundred thousand levels deep, even with the memoization. Right. And so maybe my computer can't handle that. So what if I was to instead do something a little different? What if I was to say, okay, F of zero is zero f of or sorry one f of one is one um and and i already have those those are in my table let's say i put those in first so now what is f of two well i don't have to do any recursion because i know that anything less than two has already been computed so i i
就说，嗯， f(2) 是 f(0) 加上 f(1)，并不是在那时真的去调用 f，只是把那些数字从我的全局数组里拉出来，然后把两个答案放进去，对吧？当我计算 3 时也是一样，我已经知道 0、1 和 2 已经被计算过了，所以我可以直接写出 3 的答案，写出 4 的答案。所以你甚至不需要递归。你在数学意义上有递归，但你在计算机里不需要它。你只需要一个从 1 到 100,000 的 for 循环，然后写出 100,000 个答案。那甚至更好，对吧？这就是——我用了“非递归（agglometric）”这个词，它只是一个花哨的词，用来指代，你知道，自底向上，但这就是那种你甚至不需要调用栈的
just say well f of two is f of zero plus f of one and not literally calling f in that time but just pulling those numbers out of my global array and sticking the two answer in right same thing when i go to compute three i already know that that zero one and two have already been computed and so i could just write the answer for three and write the answer for four. And so you don't even need recursion. You have recursion in a mathematical sense, but you don't need it in the computer. You just have a for loop from one to 100,000 and just write 100,000 answers. That's even better, right? And that's the, I'm using the word agglometric, which is just a fancy word for saying, you
做法。我以为你是那个意思，我不太熟悉那个词。但与你所说的相邻的事情，在教这里的东西的同一个领域里，是某种二元性，不仅仅是数学上的，也是在说递归，在计算机级别上递归是什么——这比分析那一面更符合我的背景——在计算机级别上，你所说的是存储你在哪里，跳转——我的意思是所有函数都是这样的，存储你在栈上的位置，并放入关于你想要如何调用函数的信息。所以对于斐波那契，你是说，嘿，我想要另一个斐波那契，你给它一个数字、一个索引或者
know, bottom up, but that's the way to do, where you don't even need to have the call stack. I thought you meant something different. I didn't, I'm not familiar with that word. But the adjacent thing, I think, to what you're saying, in the same realm of like stuff taught here, is the sort of duality, not just with the math but also is saying recursion what is recursion at like a computer level uh that's my background more than maybe the sort of analytical side at a computer level what you're saying is store where you were jump i mean all functions are this way sort of stare store where you are on the on the stack and put information about the how you want to invoke the function so for fibonacci you're saying hey i want this other fibonacci and you give it a number an index or
诸如此类的东西，对吧，你在说计算那个，所以我需要将我要跳转到的新函数的位置信息传达过去，但我需要存储我所有的状态。所以当你在计算机程序中这样做时，所有局部变量基本上都需要放到栈上，这样你才能再次去执行这个，对吧？这就是贾森提到的，如果你做十万次，你就会得到这个十万深的栈。嗯，那是因为所有的额外开销，当你那样做时，你弄爆计算机资源的几率要高得多。但你也可以说，嘿，使用数据结构栈和使用
whatever right and you're saying calculate that so i need to communicate to the new function of where i'm going jumping to uh that information but i need to store all of my state so when you do this in your computer program all local variables basically need to get put onto the stack uh so that you can go do this again right and that's what jason is mentioning if you do a hundred thousand you get this hundred thousand deep stack well that's because of all the extra overhead uh the chances of you blowing up your computer resources are a lot higher when you do it that way but you could also say hey there's no difference between using the sort of the data structure stack instead of
队列没有什么区别。所以我需要知道什么？我只需要知道我想在循环中，要么计算我所在的位置，要么把新东西压入栈，然后再从栈中弹出东西，对吧？所以这里的栈有一种二元性。在你的 CPU 和内存中，你的操作系统正在维护一个实际的数据结构栈。但我们也说，栈是这种概念，你知道，在你的递归中向下深入，你最终会得到这样一组流利的词，它们同时可以互换地描述所有这些，但有时你可以通过自己维护一个栈并将项目推入栈中、
q and so what do i need to know i just need to know that i want to at in a loop i want to you know either compute where i am or put new things on the stack and then pop things off the stack, right? And so the stack here has a duality. There is an actual data structure stack in your like CPU and RAM that your operating system is maintaining. But we're also saying like the stack is this sort of like concept of, you know, descending down in your recursion and you end up with this kind of like fluid set of words that kind of describe all of them at the same time interchangeably but sometimes you can get around the limit of you know an operating system depth of stack by just maintaining a stack yourself and pushing items onto it and popping
从背面弹出，来绕过操作系统栈深度的限制，其求值顺序将与你程序中的递归定义完全相同，但你消除了递归。嗯，你是还是不是？我的意思是，我想这是一个术语问题，但这也就是另一种思考方式，所以它们大致都是等价的——所有这些都是一样的，你正在执行相同的操作，但它只是实现这些结果的操作方式不同而已。是的，是的，这说得通，所以，是的，整个这种你有点像反转问题的过程——就像斐波那契的例子，你想要 f(100)，但你只是从 f(0) 开始计算，当你达到 100 时停止，这种反转的方式，你知道，
them off the back and the evaluation order would be identical to your recursive definition in your program but you've removed recursion well have you or haven't you i mean i guess it's a a terminology thing but this is the other uh sort of way of thinking about it and so all of them are roughly equivalent like all of them are the same you are doing the same operation but it's just sort of operationally how you end up achieving those results yep yep that makes sense and so yeah this whole thing where you kind of like reverse the problem like the the fibonacci example where you want f of 100 but you just start computing from f of zero and you stop when you hit 100 that way of sort of reversing it, you know,
它对斐波那契有效，对背包问题也有效，但对于绝大多数问题，它不是那样工作的。就像，就像你不能说我要，是的，我要在二分树中搜索一个数字，但我要反转问题，先检查所有的叶子节点。
it works for Fibonacci and it works for the knapsack problem, but like the vast majority of problems, it doesn't work that way. Like, like you can't say I'm going to, yeah, I'm going to search for a number in a binary tree, but I'm going to reverse the problem where I'm going to check all the leaves
就像它不，它说不通，但因为他们想教那个反转的部分，他们不能把树、二分查找和这些东西作为例子，而且正如你所说，这迫使他们选择这些非常深奥的例子。
first. Like it doesn't, it doesn't make sense, but because they want to teach that reversing part they can't use trees and binary search and these things as examples and to your point that forces them to pick these really esoteric examples um and i can tell you from personal experience like i've done a lot of recursion in different contexts mostly when dealing with graphs and stuff like that i have never ever done the thing where you reverse it like uh yeah where you reverse it and you say like i'm gonna
我从个人经验可以告诉你，我在不同的语境下做过很多递归，主要是在处理图之类的时候，我从来没有做过那种你把它反转的事情——是的，那种你把它反转，然后说我要从基本情况开始，在基本情况里构建这个广度优先的东西——我从来没有不得不这样做。你知道，哈希表现在太快了，以至于你可以用记忆化来进行递归，你从来不需要在栈里深入几十万层。所以其中很多其实都不是真正的问题，而且我认为，正如你所说，如果他们这样做，如果他们教没有最后那一步的递归，他们可以稍微拓宽一点视野，并且，是的，带着这一点，我们可以谈谈，你知道，在我们的职业生涯中，有哪些时候我们实际上使用过递归。你知道，我谈到过，在我的情况下，最大的是图。
go from the base case and build this breadth first thing in the base case i've never ever had to do that um you know hash tables are so so fast now um that you can do the recursion with memoization you have never needed to go hundreds of thousands of levels deep in the stack so a lot of these are kind of like not real problems and and i think uh to your point if they had done if if they teach uh recursion without that last step they could open up the aperture a bit um and yeah kind of with that in mind we can talk about you know what are the times you know practically like in our careers where we've used recursion you know i talked about in my case the biggest one is graphs um there's many times that
有很多次我不得不处理图。我曾在一家公司工作，我们有一个非常重要的大型社交图谱。但更重要的是所有的进程图。所以如果你对自己说，你知道，我有这个进程，它将运行并产生一个产出（artifact）。我有进程 B，它将产生另一个产出。我有进程 C，它在等待这两个产出，并且它将产生，你知道，第三个产出。所以现在你可以想象这个图，这个无环图，你拥有所有这些进程，每当你知道你的进程的条件得到满足时，你就可以开始，而这些条件构成了一个图，你经常需要
i've had to deal with graphs i worked at this company where we had this big social graph that was uh that was kind of important. But even more important were all the process graphs. So if you say to yourself, you know, I have this process, it's going to run and it's going to produce an artifact. I have process B that's going to produce another artifact. And I have process C that's waiting on those two artifacts and it's going to produce you know a third artifact so now you can kind of imagine this graph this acyclic graph where you have all these processes and whenever you know the conditions are met for your process you can get started and those conditions form a graph and you often need
对该图做各种各样的事情，以说明，你知道，这需要多长时间，或者，你知道，如果这部分失败了，什么需要重新生成。任何时候你对图做任何事情，你几乎肯定都在使用递归，因为你想看看，你知道，所有的连接是什么，不仅仅是第一跳，而且，你知道，如果这个进程失败了，所有无法运行的节点是什么，因此它最终与递归非常契合。帕特里克，你呢？我有点好奇，你可能根本没有递归，或者你有很多，我真的不知道，我们马上就会发现。是的，所以这就是我一直提出的话题，所以我的几个观察是
to do all sorts of things that graph to say you know how long is this going to take or or uh you know if this part failed what needs to be regenerated um anytime you're doing anything with graphs you're almost certainly using recursion because you want to see you know what are all the connections not just the first hop but you know if this process fails what are all the nodes that can't run and and so it ends up fitting very nicely with recursion what about you patrick i'm kind of curious you you might have zero recursion or you might have a lot i really don't know we're going to find out yeah so it was the thing i was bringing up so i mean a couple observations is
，一个是，不会太多，但二分查找是一个大头。所以那种朴素的方法，但一旦你觉得“哦，我要做二分查找，我要用递归”，你就会想“我是用循环做的”。所以，是的，这是你脑海中的递归建模，但用类似于索引追踪的方式来做，特别是正如贾森所提到的，如果你只需要单向进行——在斐波那契数列中会发生这种情况，但在其他东西中，比如二分查找也是一样，一旦你得到了最终结果，那就是尾递归，对吧？
so one is not too too much uh but for binary search is a big one so the sort of night way but then as soon as you are like oh i'm gonna do binary search i'll do recursion you're like i'm doing it in a loop uh so um yeah it is the recursive modeling in your mind but doing it sort of like with index tracking especially as jason mentioned if you're only gonna you only need to go one way sort of in the the Fibonacci sequence this happens, but in other stuff like binary search as well, like once you get to your end result, that's tail recursion, right?
就像基本上如果你得到了最终结果，你所做的只是向上返回你找到的东西，那么平心而论，递归部分——不像那种我正在计算图上的某些指标，我需要保留两者的结果，我需要来自两条不同路径的答案并进行一些计算并做出一些决策，这要复杂得多——如果你所做的只是在树中寻找某样东西，并且你处于树中的每个决策，你实际上只有单一类型的评估在进行，并且
Like basically if you get to your end result and all you're doing is returning up what you found, then to be fair, the recursive part, unlike a sort of I'm computing some metrics on a graph and I need to preserve both and I need answers from two different paths and some computation and make some decisions this is more complex if all you're doing is looking for something in a tree and you're sort of you each decision in the tree you're only sort of having a singular sort of evaluation going on and
然后你到了终点，你只是弹出、弹出、弹出、弹出、弹出、弹出、弹出，这些变得非常适合几乎不费吹灰之力地转入循环。事实上，一些编译器和某些编程语言中，这是一种第一类（first-class）处理的事情。所以二分查找，我用它来做过相当多的事情，然后就像你提到的那样，探索图。但我会说，实际上探索图是各种事物的模型。所以根据你做的方式，很多事情最终都变成了图。一些几何问题，
then you get to your end and you just pop pop pop pop pop pop pop these ones become very suitable for for moving into loops almost trivially and in fact some compilers and in some programming languages this is sort of like a first class handled thing to do so so binary search i've used it a fair amount to do that and then like you mentioned as well sort of sort of exploring graphs but i would say actually exploring graphs is a model for a variety of things. So lots of things kind of turn into graphs depending on how you sort of do. So some geometry problems
如果你有类似的东西，想象一个多边形，它周围有边。如果你在做遍历，这最终看起来可能像图遍历并且具有相似性。但即使当我提到你有一个已排序的数组并且你在做二分查找时，即使你做的是递归，它最终也会变成一树，对吧？你在原地把数组当作一树来对待。所以它也变成了一种无环图的形式。它可能
where you sort of have like, imagine a polygon and it has edges around the side. If you're doing traversals, that can end up looking like graph traversals and have a similarity. But even when I'm mentioning you have an array that's sorted and you're doing binary search, even if you're doing a recursive it ends up being a tree right you're treating the the array as a tree in place so it also becomes a form of acyclic graph it may
永远都不是那样，但它是问题的一种二元性，它只是不同的表示形式。所以通过这种方式，嗯，有点像你说的那些事情，因为我会说几乎所有以这种方式处理的问题彼此之间都有很多相似之处。是的，这说得通。当你在一些像 C++ 这样的语言中时，有没有你可以使用的记忆化库？或者有什么东西吗？我的意思是，它主要只是用哈希表写出来吗？是的，我的意思是，这是我知道的一件事，在Python中你可以添加一个装饰器（decorator）来实现记忆化，我第一次看到这个时惊呆了，我就想“什么？这太疯狂了，这是巫术”。但是，是的，我知道在C++中它只是，是的，主要是一个无序映射（unordered map），然后为你的函数参数制作某种结构并缓存它们。
not ever be that way but it is a duality of the problem it's just a different representation and so in that way um kind of the same things you're saying because i would say almost all problems that get handled this way have a lot of similarity to each other yeah that makes sense when you um um in some of these languages like c++ is there like a memoization library that you can use or is there anything i mean is it mostly just coding it out of hash tables yes uh i mean this is one of the things i know in python you can add a decorator which i was blown away the first time i saw this to memoize and i was just like what this is crazy uh this is voodoo but uh yeah i know in c++ it's just yeah mostly an unordered map and then making some structure
是的，你知道，不想在这里偏离主题太远，但像，想象一下，如果你有一个函数，它所做的全部事情就是它在前面做一些工作，它调用你的，它调用另一个函数，然后在后面做一些工作，你可以，你可以把它变成一个装饰器。所以在 Python 中，就像一个装饰器几乎可以做任何事情，并且，并且，是的，装饰器非常强大。我们最近在工作时，我们创建了一个装饰器，你知道，你使用 @ 符号，我不记得他们叫它什么了，但你知道，它会做的是获取你函数的输出，在返回之前它会像把它存储在数据库中一样。所以你可以用装饰器做各种非常有趣的事情，但在底层，我认为，Python 利用的事实是所有东西都是可哈希的（hashable）。我认为在 C++ 中，怎么——哦，是的，我认为在 C++ 中有一个你必须实现的东西，对吧？有一个类似接口的东西，像哈希类型或类似的东西。是的，如果你想把它插入标准的哈希表中，你需要重写，所以要么它是可哈希的，要么你必须提供一种对它进行哈希处理的方法。明白了，好的。但，是的，我想为了，嗯，包装，包装那部分，所以你知道，我们讨论了斐波那契的例子，你知道，你去计算 f(98)，你在你的表格里看到，哦，第 98 个元素里面有东西，所以
for your function arguments and caching them yeah you know the thing about not to go on too much of a tangent here but like you know imagine if you have a function and it all it does is it does some work up front it calls your it calls another function and then does some work afterwards uh you can you can make that a decorator so in python like a decorator can do just about anything um and uh and so yeah the decorators are extraordinarily powerful we recently at work um we created a decorator where you know you do at sign i don't remember what they called it but you know and what it will do is take the output of your function and before returning it will like store it in a database um and so you could do all sorts of really fun stuff
这意味着我已经计算过了。如果你的递归是，参数要复杂得多，对吧？比如，如果你看过的名字列表是递归函数的输入呢？嗯，你必须有一种方法说，哦，我已经看过这群人了。所以这意味着最终是哈希。你需要某种类型的哈希表，某种类型的单向哈希，你把输入放进去，不管它有多复杂，你把它变成一个单一的数字，
with with decorators but under the hood i think um what python takes advantage of is the fact that everything is hashable um i think with c++ um how does oh yeah i think with c++ there's like a something you have to implement right there's like an interface interface like a hash type or something like that yeah you need to override if you want to insert it into a standard hash table so ask the either hashable or you have to provide a way of it being hashed got it okay but yeah i guess just to kind of uh wrap wrap that part of it up so you know we talked about the feminace example where you know you go to compute f of 98 and you see in your table that oh the 98th element has something in it so So that means I've already computed that. What if your recursion is like the arguments are a lot more complicated, right? Like
然后你就可以回去再次查找那个项目。在我们结束对斐波那契数列的讨论之前，为了防止有人写信来纠正我们，但是斐波那契数列是一个非常常见的，我不知道为什么它在计算机科学中被教授，或者实际上我知道。它有这样一个有趣的属性，
what if it's a list of people's names that you've already looked at? That is the input to the recursive function. Well, you have to have a way of saying, oh, I've looked at this set of people already. And so what that means is ultimately is hashing. You need to have some type of hash table, some type of one-way hash where you take the input, regardless of how complicated it is, you turn it into a single number,
它与黄金分割率（phi）相关，当你除以连续的斐波那契数时，它是对这个常数 phi 越来越近的近似。所以这让人觉得很有趣，但这是卢卡斯数列（Lucas sequence，L-U-C-A-S）更广泛的一部分，卢卡斯数列就是所有以这种方式定义的递归函数，而斐波那契碰巧是那种有两个连续项，且前两个数字是 1 的情况。但这是被讨论的那一个，不过也确实有其他真正
and so then you can go back and look for that item again. Before we finish our discussion of Fibonacci sequences to save someone from writing us in, but Fibonacci sequence is like a very common, I don't know why it gets taught in CS, or actually I do. It's this like interesting property
迷人的属性，还有很多其他的，我想我没说错吧，卢卡斯数。我想如果你看 Numberphile 的 YouTube，有一个关于这个的 Numberphile 视频，他们深入探讨了它，它有点像那种，是什么来着，是 tau 对 pi，对吧？就像 tau 比 pi 更优越，不管怎样，它就像是那种在网上激烈争论的辩论之一。没错，如果有人在这里觉得“啊，他们在这里给了斐波那契数列更多赞誉”，这是对卢卡斯数列的致敬。是的，工作中有个人在庆祝 Tau 日，这导致我陷入了这个互联网兔子洞，我不知道我出来时是不是变得更聪明了，但我对 Tau 了解了很多。所以我想我当时疯狂地在谷歌上搜索他们到底在谈论什么。
where it's associated with phi, where you divide sequential Fibonacci numbers and it is a closer and closer approximation of this numerical constant phi. So this is very entertaining to people, but this is a broader part of the Lukas sequence, L-U-C-A-S, which is just all these recursive functions defined this way, and Fibonacci happens to be the one where it's two consecutive, and the first two numbers are one. But this is the one that gets talked about but there's also really other
是的，嗯，你可能还记得这个，就像 Tau 是某种常数，就像 Pi 是，它是两个 Pi，这就是全部。哦，好的。它是两倍的 Pi，或者 Pi 是半个 Tau。无论你喜欢给哪一个以先例。明白了。是的，有，天哪，我们绝对应该做个节目。这在这里有点跑题了。我很乐意做一个关于分形（fractals）的节目，以及整个，你知道，分形走向无穷大和不走向无穷大的空间点。
fascinating properties and a lot of the other i think i'm saying that right luca numbers uh i think there's like if you watch number file youtube there's like a number file video about this where they go into it's sort of one of those uh what is it it's tau versus pi right like tau is superior instead of pi and anyways it's like one of those like uh debates that get raging online that's right if someone's here like ah they're giving more credit to fibonacci sequence here's your shout out to the lukas sequence yeah there was somebody at work who was celebrating tau day and it caused me to go down this internet rabbit hole where i don't know if i came out of it any smarter but i learned a lot about tau um so i guess i like frantically googling what are they
我完全想不起来那叫什么了。就像那些，那些分形图，像谢尔宾斯基垫片（Sierpinski gasket）这样的，你在说什么？不，那是芒德布罗特集（Mandelbrot set），那是我在想的。所以，是的，芒德布罗特集是，想象一下，如果在某个网格上的每一个点，你绘制出，如果你把那个当作输入，输出达到无穷大需要多长时间，或者它是否达到无穷大，诸如此类的事情。我想这是，因为，那是我们没有真正讨论的一件事，你知道，斐波那契，你知道，有一个基本情况。所以最终，你知道，它会导致某个数字。但你可以想象，如果你走向相反的方向，它只会爆炸到无穷大，除非你相加的数字也变得无限小。
talking about now yeah um i you probably remember this like tau is some type of constant like pi is is uh it's two pi it's just that's all it is oh Oh, okay. It's twice pi, or pi is half tau. However you prefer to like give precedent. Got it. Yeah, there's, oh man, we should definitely do a show. It's a little out of scope here. I'd love to do a show on fractals and the whole like, you know, the points on the space where the fractal goes to infinity and where it doesn't go to infinity.
所以如果你相加，你知道，二分之一加三分之一加四分之一加五分之一，你相加的数字变得无限小。所以即使你要走向无穷大，你实际上也在接近一个常数。这有点奇怪。是的，所以芒德布罗特集是你取笛卡尔平面的 X 和 Y 值，并将它们作为复数的输入。当你将复数相乘时，有时它们最终会收敛，有时
I'm totally drawing a blank on uh what is that thing called it's like those those plots those fractal plots like a syrin penske gasket like what are you no it's a mandelbrot set that's what i was thinking of so yeah the mandelbrot set is you imagine if at every point on some grid you plotted like how long it takes for if you use that as an input how long it takes for the output to reach uh infinity or whether it reaches infinity or not something like that i think it's uh because oh that's one thing we didn't really talk about is you know fibon Fibonacci, you know, has a has a base case. And so eventually, you know, it kind of results in some number. But you can imagine if you kind of went the other direction, it would just explode to infinity unless the numbers you're adding are also getting infinitely small.
不会，所以这就是你在这种递归关系中一遍又一遍相乘的地方，它在什么地方发散得非常非常快，发散得很慢，或者收敛。如果你把这些绘制出来，你最终会得到一个非常令人惊讶的复杂形状。是的，完全正确，完全正确。我想我，我不知道这是否对任何人有帮助。我们会在分形上做一个完整的节目，分形真的非常非常有趣，我们会给我们的大脑一些时间从递归中休息一下，我们会在几个月后做一个分形节目。所以，是的，我想，你知道，也许我们可以过一遍，你知道，如何以一种循序渐进的方式用递归解决问题。所以想象一下你，你知道，在一生一次的 LeetCode 竞赛中，或者类似的事情，你有一个，你知道，或者甚至在你的日常工作中，你必须用递归解决问题。你总是告诉人们的第一步是写出
So if you add, you know, half plus a third plus a fourth plus a fifth, a fifth, the numbers you're adding are getting infinitely small. And so even though you're going to infinity, you're actually approaching a constant. It's kind of a weird thing. Yeah, so the Mandelbrot set is you're taking the X and Y value of a Cartesian plane and using them as inputs to complex numbers. And when you multiply complex numbers, sometimes they end up converging and
基本情况，并确保它非常全面。所以，你知道，我会看到很多问题的一点是，它类似于“好的，f(x 减 10) 加上 f(x 减 1)”，假设我们有那种函数。如果我有那个，那么，你知道我对于负 6 的基本情况是什么？发生了什么？——如果我调用 f(4)，这导致我调用 f(负 6)，那是，那是可以的吗？如果我不能有负数，现在 4 需要是一个基本情况——我需要以某种特殊方式处理它。所以要确保没有任何漏洞，并且你总是最终落入这些返回常数
sometimes they don't and so that's what like you're multiplying over and over in this sort of recursive relationship and where it diverges very very quickly diverges slowly converges and if you plot those out you end up with a very surprisingly complex shape yeah exactly exactly i think i i don't know if this is helping anyone well we'll do a whole show on fractals fractals are really really fun um we'll give our brain some time to rest from recursion and we'll do a fractal show in a few months um so yeah i think uh you know maybe we could kind of walk through you know how to solve problems with recursion kind of a step-by-step way so imagine you're you know in the elite code competition of a lifetime or something and you have uh uh you know or even you're in your day job and you have to to uh solve a problem with recursion the first step you always tell folks is to write out the
或可以轻松计算的东西的口袋（pockets）之一。一旦你有了基本情况，并且你看了这个并说，哦，这是全面的，然后你构建递归步骤。类似于我之前所说的，当你构建那个步骤时，这是一个好时机，以确保你没有，你知道，你的所有基本情况都涵盖了你可以调用它的所有方式，并且这非常困难，你必须很大程度上依靠直觉并仔细阅读方程。然后我会说，你知道，一旦你有了那个，你就可以有选择地添加记忆化，你知道，如果你在全局上下文中做事，比如如果你在从文件读取，或者如果你在检查互联网之类的事情，好吧，那么你就不能记忆化，因为也许你调用 f(4) 两次，你得到两个不同的答案，如果那是刻意设计的，现在你就不能记忆化了。所以理想情况下，你把导致你的 f(4) 不同的任何外部东西拿出来，然后你把它变成输入之一。所以你的输入之一是，你知道，今天的天气或者类似的东西。所以你让它——我想这个词是幂等的（idempotent）。你让它使得每次你用这些输入调用函数时，你都得到完全相同的输出。然后你添加记忆化，你就万事俱备了。至于测试递归的东西，帕特里克，你绝对应该聊聊你在你的语境中如何测试你的。但在我的情况下，我通常有一种生成
base case and make sure it's really comprehensive so you know one thing i'll see a lot of problems is where it's like okay f of x minus 10 plus f of x minus 1 let's assume we have that kind of function if i have that then you know what's my base case for like negative 6 like what happens like if i call f of four and that causes me to call f of negative six like is that is that okay if i can't have f of negative numbers now four needs to be a base case like i need to handle that in some special way so like make sure that there aren't any holes and that you always end up landing in one of these one of these pockets where you're returning a constant
输入和输出的方法。所以大多数时候，如果你在做这个，比如这个关于试图看看一个工作需要多长时间的例子，如果你，比方说这个工作是一个好例子，你可以说，好吧，我想要这个工作花费 60 秒，我想要答案是 60，我将只除以，我将把这个数字 60 的部分放在我的图里。所以我将有，你知道，在这个图里有一个链，它加起来等于 60，然后我要制造一大堆其他的链，它们具有类似于 1 e 的负 6 次方的时间，我知道它们永远不会像那 60 秒那样长。然后我运行我的单元测试，我应该拿回 60。如果我没有，那么事情就糟透了。
or something that can be easily computed. Once you have the base cases and you've kind of looked at this and said, oh, this is comprehensive, then you build the recursive step. And similar to what I said before, when you're building that step, it's a good time to make sure that you're not you know that you're all of your base cases are covering all the ways you can call that and it's very hard to do this you have to rely a lot on intuition and just reading the equation carefully then I would say you know once you have that then you could optionally add memoization um you know if you are doing things in a global context like if you're reading from a file or if you're you know checking the internet or something well then you can't memoize because maybe you call f of four twice you get two different answers and and if that's by design now you can't memoize so ideally you take whatever that
而在九成的情况下，当我写出这样的测试时，它确实糟透了。所以测试递归的东西真的非常非常重要。是的，测试很重要。我会说，我会对此即兴发挥一下，并说对我来说，特别是在开始时，以及无论你的语言的契约（contracts）是什么，
external thing is that's causing your f of four to be different and you and you make that one of the inputs so one of your inputs is you know the weather today or something like that so you make it so it's i think the word is idempotent you Make it so that every time you call the function with these inputs, you get exactly the same output. Then you add memoization, and you should be good to go. As far as testing recursive things, Patrick, you should definitely chat about how you test yours in your context. But in my case, I usually have a way of generating uh inputs and outputs
这基本上是添加检查，比如你处于什么深度级别。所以保持一个计数器并说：“哦，嘿，我处于这个级别，你知道，一百左右。”这是意料之中的还是意料之外的？
so most of the time if you're doing this like this example with um trying to see how long a job is going to take um you can if you for example the job is a good example you can say well i have i want this job to take 60 seconds i want the answer to be 60 and i'm going to just divide i'm going to put portions of this number 60 in my graph so i'm going to have you know uh a chain in this graph that's going to add up to 60 and then i'm going to make a whole bunch of other chains that have like one e to the negative six time where i know that they're never going to take as long as that 60. And then I run my unit test and I should get back 60. If I don't, then something has gone horribly wrong.
然后添加一些东西，给你一个很好的、有帮助的打印语句或断言，说明这些东西绝不应该超过 100，或者在你的记忆化映射中不能有那么多结果，或者诸如此类，并且至少在最初添加一些边界检查，只是为了确保你不会陷入那种令人沮丧的循环中，你知道你在计算成千上万的东西，它只是崩溃了，而你弄不清楚原因。所以我觉得这非常有用。或者贾森之前暗示过，虽然它不会为你做这件事，但正如你已经开发了一段时间那样，想出创造性的方法来可视化调用图，无论是在你的调试器中（这可能仍然相当困难），
And nine times out of 10, when I write a test like that, it actually is horribly wrong. So testing recursive stuff is really, really important. Yeah, testing is important. I would say like, I'll riff on it a bit and say like for me, especially at least in the beginning and with whatever your languages contracts are for,
还是在你的输出中，拥有某种 ASCII 图案或其他东西，告诉你你处于什么级别，或者东西是如何嵌套的，或者在开头添加更多空格——我做过各种各样的事情，我认为这真的很有用。所以在单元测试语境下没那么有用，但在“哦不，出问题了，我该如何，你知道，把它重新控制住”的语境下，我认为这些东西会非常有用。是的，这是一个绝佳绝佳的观点。总的来说，你应该编写你的程序，使其永远不会永远运行，因为那是调试起来最痛苦的事情。所以，特别是如果你把你的程序给别人——这是一段人们会安装在他们计算机上的软件，它只是永远运行，你知道，
which is basically adding checks for like what level of depth you're at. So keeping a counter and saying, Oh, Hey, I'm at level, you know, a hundred or whatever. Is that something expected or something unexpected?
烧光他们的电池，或者只是，你知道，阻止他们的计算机进入睡眠状态——这些都是你应该避免的事情。所以帕特里克完全正确，我写过的每一个实际应用中的递归，总是带有某种检查，上面写着：“嘿，你知道，我已经调用这个函数一万次了，这是不可能发生的。我从不期望有人拥有长达一万个单位的工作流，所以我只是要中止。”我想我们有时会被这个坑到，是因为人们会做他们认为像数学一样的事情。所以每隔一段时间，我们会遇到一些没有封闭形式解的计算，也就是没有一种在有限时间内解决它的直接方法，所以你会用牛顿法来解决它——我们没有谈过这个，但这基本上是一样的——
And just adding something that gives yourself a nice helpful print statement or an assertion that says these things shouldn't be ever more than 100 or have more than so many results in your memoization map or whatever right and sort of adding some bounds checking at least initially just to make sure you don't get into that frustrating loop where you know you're computing thousands and thousands of things and it's just breaking and you can't kind of figure out why so i think that's very helpful um or jason was kind of alluding to it before that it doesn't do it for you but as you've been developing for a while coming up with creative ways to visualize the like call graph either you know in your debugger which can still be pretty difficult
我们以迭代的方式谈论它，但它在某种程度上也是递归定义的，事实上，人们经常会递归地定义它们，并且你不会终止，因为你最终会陷入某种状态，由于数值稳定性和浮点数等等，你在两个值之间振荡。所以确保有人在追踪，就像我们说的，需要多长时间，但这通常可能很昂贵或很难做到，但只是像你进行了多少次迭代，并设置一些合理的“最大迭代次数”，如果它不管用，要么报告有错误，要么就说：听着，你已经够接近了——就对付着用吧。但是，是的，我想确保代码，像贾森，我确实偶尔会写 `while(true)` 或 `forever`，它总是真的很吓人，因为我想这真的很……我应该只写……我确实偶尔会写 `while(true)` 或 `forever`。
but like in your outputs like having some ascii pattern or something that tells you what level you're at or how the stuff is nested or adding more spaces to the beginning i've done various things i think this can be really useful so not in the unit testing context so much but in the like uh-oh something has gone wrong like how do i you know get it back under control i think these these kinds of things can be very helpful yeah that's a phenomenal phenomenal point like in general if you you should write your program such that it never runs forever um because that is the most painful thing to have to debug and so um especially if you're giving your program to someone else like this is a piece of software that people are going to install in their computer and it just runs forever and you know
但是比如在你的输出中，有一些 ASCII 图案或其他东西告诉你你处于哪一层，或者这些东西是如何嵌套的，或者在开头添加更多的空格，我做过各种各样的事情，我认为这真的很有用，所以与其说是在单元测试的语境下，不如说是在“糟了，出事了”的情况下，我该如何把它重新控制住，我认为这类事情会非常有用，是的，这是一个绝佳绝佳的观点，比如总的来说，你应该编写你的程序，使其永远不会无限运行，因为这是调试起来最痛苦的事情，所以尤其是如果你把程序交给其他人，比如这是一个人们要在他们的电脑上安装的软件，它却一直在运行，你知道的
burns their battery or or just you know it keeps their computer from going to sleep these are all things you should avoid and so paddock is exactly right every single recursion i've written in practice always has some type of check that says hey you know i've called this function you know 10 000 times that that can never happen i i never expect someone to have a workflow of 10 000 units long and so i'm just going to abort i think where we get bit by that sometimes is uh people will do what they think is like a mathematical thing so every so often we'll run across uh a some computation that doesn't have a closed form solution that is there isn't a direct way of solving it in a finite time and so you'll use newton's method to solve it which is we didn't talk about this but this is basically the same
耗尽他们的电池，或者只是让他们的电脑无法进入睡眠状态，这些都是你应该避免的事情，所以帕多克说得完全没错，我在实践中写过的每一个递归，总是带有某种类型的检查，比如嘿，你知道的，我已经调用这个函数一万次了，这是绝不可能发生的事情，我从不期望有人会有一个长达一万个单位的工作流，所以我打算直接中止，我认为我们有时会被这一点坑到的地方在于，人们会做他们认为是数学性质的事情，所以每隔一段时间，我们会遇到某种没有封闭形式解的计算，也就是说，没有在有限时间内解决它的直接方法，所以你会用牛顿法来解决它，我们没有讨论过这个，但这基本上是一样的
we talk about it iteratively but it is also somewhat recursively defined and in fact often people will define them recursively and you won't terminate because you'll end up in some state where you're oscillating between two values because of numerical stability and floating point or whatever yeah and so like making sure that someone is keeping track of like we say how long but often that can be expensive or difficult to do but just like how many iterations you've gone and just set some like maximum iteration count that's reasonable and if it didn't work either report that there was an error or just say look you're close enough like it just deal with it um but yeah i think like making sure code like jason i i have i do occasionally write while true or for ever uh it always really scares me because i'm like this is really i should just write I do occasionally write while true or forever.
我们以迭代的方式讨论它，但它在某种程度上也是递归定义的，事实上，人们经常会用递归来定义它们，而且你不会终止，因为由于数值稳定性和浮点数等等原因，你最终会陷入某种在两个值之间震荡的状态，所以确保有人在追踪比如我们所说的时长，但通常这可能代价高昂或难以做到，而只是追踪你进行了多少次迭代，并设置一些合理的“最大迭代次数”，如果不管用，要么报告说有错误，要么就说：看，你已经足够接近了，就这样吧，但是是的，我认为确保代码像杰森那样——我偶尔确实会写 while true 或 forever，它总是让我感到非常害怕，因为我觉得这真的很……我确实偶尔会写 while true 或 forever。
It always really scares me because I'm like, this is really, I should just write while, some counter is less than a million or something. Because it's really scary to write just a loop forever. Even however many years I've been programming, I still get scared to write loops that don't have an auto exit condition because you'll mess something up and it'll just run forever. And that's a very frustrating thing for people after you bumping into.
这总是让我感到很害怕，因为我觉得，这真的很……我真该用“某个计数器小于一百万”之类的条件来写循环。因为写一个无限循环真的让人很害怕。不管我已经编程了多少年，我写没有自动退出条件的循环时依然会感到害怕，因为你可能会弄砸什么东西，然后它就会无限运行下去。对于遇到这种情况的人来说，这绝对是一件非常令人沮丧的事情。
Yeah, I mean, one practical example of this recently was I was writing some code that was interpreting JSON. So I had this JSON object and json object was recursive you could have modules that had modules um so you could have objects that have objects and uh and but you know the recursion was pretty limited like you'd never really go more than three levels deep but i had a bug where you know i was reading my object and then instead of reading all the children objects i read my own object oh no that many times for however many children there were and uh um yeah and it just never ended and and the worst thing too is the way because it blew up the call
对，我的意思是，最近这方面的一个实际例子是，我当时在写一段解释JSON的代码。我有一个JSON对象，这个JSON对象是递归的，你可以有包含模块的模块，嗯……所以你可以有嵌套对象的对象，然后呢……但你知道，递归其实是相当有限的，你永远不会真正进入超过三层深度的地方。但我有个Bug，你知道的，我当时在读取我的对象，然后我没有去读所有的子对象，而是反复读取了我自己的对象，哦不，为每一个子对象重复了无数次，然后……嗯……对，它就永远不会结束了。最糟糕的是，因为这导致了调用
stack it caused like my computer to act all weird and you get these kind of weird things or your mouse slows down if you start blowing up the memory and everything so so yeah just yet another data point for uh putting some type of constraint like if you know you're never going to call us more than 10 times you know 10 levels deep and just add one of your inputs you know uh how deep am i and uh, and if it's, you know, 20 or something, you know that you're in trouble. Cool. All right. Well, that was a recursion. You know, if you have any other questions, don't hesitate, you know, leave comments, reply to us on X, or send us an email. i'll be happy to to continue the discussion over
栈溢出，导致我的电脑表现得很诡异，你会遇到这种奇怪的现象，或者如果内存开始爆满，你的鼠标就会变慢等等。所以，是的，这又提供了一个数据点，那就是设置某种限制，比如如果你知道自己绝不会调用超过10次，或者说10层深度，只要在你的输入中加上……你知道的，我现在有多深？如果达到了20层左右，你就知道出问题了。太好了。好吧，这就是递归。你知道，如果你有任何其他问题，请不要犹豫，留下评论，在X上回复我们，或者给我们发邮件。我非常乐意在那里继续讨论
there but uh yeah i want to give a huge thanks to all of our patron uh patreon patrons all of our subscribers thank you so much for all of your support and uh we'll see you all next time no we'll see them in episode 163, Recursion. That's amazing. See you all later. See you guys. Music by Eric Barndollar. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不过，是的，我要对我们所有的Patreon赞助者、所有的订阅者表示由衷的感谢，非常感谢你们所有的支持，我们下次再见——不对，我们将在第163期节目“递归”中再见。太棒了。大家再见。伙计们再见。音乐由Eric Barndollar提供。《Programming Throwdown》在知识共享 署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，可以进行混音和改编，但你必须署名我和帕特里克，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。